tu as vu ce qui se passe à tous au nom
de quoi tu parles tu rigoles ou quoi la
radio ou à la télé les journaux tout le
monde enfin à le truc mais oui ce matin
chez lui au précis m'attends à tout
moment pas à l'autre c'est foutu c'est
que je crois qu'en ligne l'aventuré en
parler aussi mieux c'est encore un bruit
aussi le passif il emballe ça veut dire
que tout le monde
[Applaudissements]
bienvenue sur le plateau de tout le
monde en parle l'émission pas comme les
autres vous connaissez le principe tout
le monde en parle alors tout le monde en
parle
vous connaissez l'équipe si jean marie
bigard
je vous aurais été je vous demande de
vous inviter à beaucoup de choses ce
soir n'est pas venu pour rien un livre
un disque un film la scène aussi bien
entendu et puis toujours l'opération
bouchons on a du pain sur la planche
veut et on va en parler longuement je
suis très longuement aller ça
m'arrangerait mois
[Musique]
oh
mise à part jean marie bigard je
recevrai ce soir
lambert wilson
non rien
jackson richardson
[Applaudissements]
sharleen spiteri de texas
et sylvie joly
oh
mais
edouard detrez la blind thèse masyaf il
encore dit
oui
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
dimanche à l'ats philippe
là bas
alors suivi postnatal n'y avait pas là
non bah non c'est pour éviter pendant
bêtement à tous les gars j'ai reçu un
email de julien du havre qui dit thierry
je n'en peux plus après ton émission je
dors sur la béquille talia ans mes nuits
voilà d'ailleurs vient quand le remède
il va pouvoir dormir ce soir tranquille
mais samedi prochain le sera là aïe aïe
aïe
[Musique]
savez vous le savez une tradition dans
cette émission
une tradition qui est reprise dans le
monde entier sur france 3 comme noël ou
halloween c'est eux diffusés chaque
semaine les meilleurs moments de la
semaine précédente
ça s'appelle tout le monde a parlé et
s'est préparé par jean yves nau l1 et
auxerre
quarante ans après ça marche toujours
c'est incroyable ça compte énormément la
guerre quand même un premier titre
revient à sophie way après j'ai crié
aline pour qu'elle revienne mais il ya
eu de la gueule
comment ça va ça va comme quelqu'un qui
s'est couché tard en effet j'ai fait du
découpage que 90 du découpage
oui c'est pour ça que j'ai c'est parce
que le découpage ces découpages de cette
nuit elle dit quoi la m vous étiez
petits milliards semblait acquis avec la
taille à qui marilyn monroe
j'aurais aimé avoir des gros nichons
fait aborder la terre entière ouais
quelle est la dernière chose que vous
faites le soir avant de vous coucher
découpage martial allemands et des
coloriages
j'ai trois mois de prison ferme
on a droit à des visites mans oui il
faut que vous demander au juge je pense
qu est-ce que parlera sexuellement les
prisons en france en espagne un bon mais
il faudrait que ça vient d'en venir à
toi à moi j'ai eu jusqu'à 6 heures
c'est le bordel
musique prison c'est génial attention
pas totalement l'ivoirienne petite
bouille il pas justement c'est ça qui
est excitant
depuis quatre ans je fais peur avec tout
ce qui m'arrive parce que imaginez vous
un homme m'approche vous savez ce qu'il
risque depuis quatre ans alors des
pompes quand il finit par être
judiciaire annonce sytadin piscine on va
faire un test on va l'augmenter de
contrôle fiscal baffie est épatant y
avait des vaches et des graves
j'aurai le lendemain regardez moi bien
l'y nastase est ce que sucer c'est
tromper je sais pas je ne parle pas bien
français et le mot trompé qui n'a pas
compris alors vous attaquer à cette
époque-là ce même choix de vie privée on
a même dit que j'étais homosexuel
j'ai beaucoup bougé sur chose que je
peux être c'est peut être lesbienne mais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
des soucis et lee qui est écroulé de
rire on ne sait pas qui sera là qu'est
ce qui se passe il a parlé de quelques
ce très grand on peut dire il ya une
[ __ ] à la place de charles baudelaire
mettre encore les grosses grosses lances
pas mon truc
ou alors
machine et revient à montrer comme ça je
pourrai juger sur pièce on est bloqué
tous les deux dans une bergerie dans la
montagne vous et moi il ya la police
française tout autour qui nous assiège
je meurs de froid vous êtes obligé de me
manger vous commencez par quoi non ce ne
peut pas arriver ça super est bloqué
dans une bergerie avec moi et qu'on est
susceptible d'être encerclés par la
police sur un tunnel
monsieur jean
[Musique]
jean marie bigard à vous alors non mais
le livre le dise le film la scène
l'opération bouchons leur va le faire
une fois pour tout est prêt
dans les cantonales tour de trucs à
vendre c'est normal en même temps c'est
normal
or le bouquin alors c'est votre premier
bouquin oui ça s'appelle non mais pour
qui je me prends oui chez albin michel
alors c'était un livre il faut regarder
c'est un livre de fallait regarder ccc
né de mon site internet j'avais
j'ai un photomontage chaque jour là ça
commence par marianne vous savez où je
me les met les doigts de l'homme
voyez par exemple quand je vois ce que
je fais il rien que d'urssaf tous les
mois je suis vert jeu sans fin quoi t'as
vu d'ailleurs tu as pu le lire
entièrement âgées c'est à dire que je
vais aussi de 50 kg pour faire le rôle
puis finalement ils ont pris robert de
niro miss world to [ __ ] j'ai su si
tout le monde peut rien mais là je suis
en colère j'ai envie de me gratter les
couilles mais je peux pas jamais tu
lâches à mettre la charrue avant les
boeufs
bien sûr il est ici je vous disais
discrédit un rasta qui a arrêté de fumer
non mais qu'est ce que c'est que cette
musique de merde donc jean marie bigard
ce moment et puis alors il ya ça et puis
aussi un disque oui aussi un disque vous
allez pas de main morte
[Musique]
j'image autres je suis pas compositeur
j'ai pas danser bouger
mais quand j'entends ce genre de
décibels je crois mon et là je me plais
dans ce jeu ballon
je joue je
et je crois
et je remue l'euro et je regarde
toujours
[Musique]
jma vendus
tony
il s'entraîne
je
entre les deux oreilles
exactement pas valide
plus austère
laffont 3 moi j'ai la larme comme ça je
m'emmerde
non
là
[Musique]
c'est parti pour fair l'été ça va on a
longtemps hésité entre je voulais dire
quand même entre la la la la la
et on april à lallaing monsieur c'est
plus vendeur c'est plus original auquel
le livre il ya le disque puis elle filme
aussi qui va sortir s'appelle la boîte
de nuit le 4 juillet en l'histoire c'est
une bande de potes qui sont interdits
d'accès dans l'est dans les discothèques
de la région pendant un an et par des
jurés à une boîte de nuit donc dans le
garage du père de l'un d'eux et la boîte
s'appelle la boîte est très vite ça
devient l'endroit très à la mode où tous
les jeunes des alentours vont faire la
fête
ce qui ne fait pas les affaires de roger
vous roger moi c'est un gros con qui
tient le macumba ça le fait bien chier
que les petits jeunes qui arrivent à
monter une boîte donc je leur créer tout
un tas de d'emmerdements je suis copain
avec les flics faisant peser des
relations crapuleuses et exactement donc
et c'était très très amusant de faire de
faire ce rôle et puis alors il ya la
scène bigard remet le paquet ya encore
des dates d'ici l'été bigard remet le
paquet et qu'il y ait encore des dates
tu plaisantes tuant gore 90 dates
jusqu'à la fin de l'année je fais que
des zénith dé parc expo et surtout c'est
vrai c'est le seul qui met dix mille
personnes non et merci et merci donc van
persie est là bercy allait falloir
bigard bourg bercy c'est le 28 décembre
un gardois bercy ça fait un peu vulgaire
vous remercie en même temps bon merci à
les impôts qu'ils ont pas loin c'est
vrai que les bronzés donc aimé le kiff
c'est de jouer
douze mille personnes en une seule fois
et peut-être de le faire donc il ya
aucun comme mais qui fait ça non et
c'est mais ce qui est génial c'est que
j'aurai jamais voulu faire ça j'ai
jamais voulu le faire c'est le spectacle
qui le qui le veut on va faire un espèce
de théâtre avec des drapeaux rouges
il ya deux énormes écrans donc tout le
monde sera au septième rang et ça c'est
vraiment magnifique tu peux pas savoir
l'impression que ça fait que tu rentres
tu fais une mimique et que tu as dix
mille personnes qui rigolent en même
temps c'est une drogue dure que je
comprends et j'ai l'impression que je me
suis fait bouffer par le système allait
de me parler d'une catégorie des gens là
on en a tous un dans la fabrique
tous vous parmi les amis allaient des
gens qui font semblant de reboucher les
pots de moutarde ou de compétition
je parle pas des gens qui les retouches
parent se sent sont fous nous en cause
derrière ont l'air bouge
non je parle des gens qui font des
messieurs il faut semblant ses dires il
repose le couvercle mais il ne vit pas
parce que après c'est toujours dans des
situations d'urgence un jour le matin
que tu es vachement près c'était pas
aller au boulot tu dire j'ai bûché juste
avalé un petit yaourt run aller au
travail tout bleu la botte du frigidaire
et dans le cas où il ya le fameux pot de
moutarde
donc tu le sors
et il clôt janvier j'aurai d'étonner
alors là les différentes techniques toi
comme tu connais pas les hurlements
primaires parce que je t'aime encore
expliqué
différents réglages qui font appel
respiration d'accouchement
c'est pour éviter de tuer un proche du
roi dame
dans la seconde qui suit après faut un
rapide bilan de la situation comme une
éponge je dire la grosse tache cicek a
sauté sur leur sur le costume un petit
que celui chaussures et y laisse sécher
ça le soir va taper gare venir avec un
marteau et un burin pour essayer de
déconner tu essaies l'épousé et petits
bouts de fer bien planté un autre à ses
choix en essayant d parviennent à sauver
et ben qui n'ont pas déjà été fait
28 pts hormis les jeunes qui vont bonne
vieille non-provoquées police stoppent
jeudi un amas de faire dominer par les
30 secondes
alors maintenant je vais vous donner un
exemple concret vous faut pratiquer lure
le mot primaire jean vous êtes dans une
salle d'attenté de médecin ça le temps
normal donc on est gratuite
tassé sur les banquettes les fauteuils
doigt sur les coins de pots de fleurs
qui les attend pas
ça fait une heure quarante deux années
dans des trucs le médecin et paris n'en
sais pas pourquoi
en juin et alors rien elle même qu'elle
a eu avec son petit garçon celui genou
et petit garçon ce fichier voilà des
cent des jeunes odeurs sa vie va vers la
table qui suit vial revu son milieu
robin haase a abondé une revue et appuie
la déchire fait vertige bang phlat après
pour la revue d'abonnés des chiffres à
savoir la personne mais barry guy que du
feu motive
bolbec déchirer les cheveux d'or mavs
paquet petite idée celle des journaux
allez viens vous doutez bien que nous
avons mans alors vraiment originaux et
sa mère deux minutes après à décembre
c'est la star
legault des tagueurs pas encore une
autre vie ap c'est bien à déchirer ta
bulle en coin en haut des godets la
seconde a obtenu que seul lui maman
maman à l'indienne packaging mais sa
balle nadal est bien jolie venue à maman
à la vie qui revient là il remonte même
pas sur les genoux et à sa mère un il
fait juste un petit sourire
la mère de dire je t'emmerde thérapie
les accords rivage a rien au bout de la
8ème révèle le livre le mot primaire et
moi ce que je fais parce que là je me
lève je vois la bonne femme judy mais
laissez-moi y met une claque dans la
gueule d'un geste
les séries oui il va vous aimez pareil
qu'avant moi il va me détester mais on
s'en fout on se connaît pas pardon ça va
des landes tout le monde la salle
d'attenté dépassaient le directeur de la
classe
jean mallot
dix ans
là
j'imagine que ça rentre bien oui ça
c'est clair
alors il ya toujours l'opération
bouchons là comment ça se passe
exactement bien alors bat toujours
pareil les petits bouchons on peut y
accéder par par année par l'e-mail bien
sûr par l'internet www.gout.ch d'amour
points comme bouchon au pluriel d'amour
sans d apostrophes coin comme un ou la
boîte postale et
et voilà doit garder on doit garder des
bouchons en plastique du lait de l'eau
tous les déchets de bois sont le bois
sont tous les bouchons de boissons
d'aller alors voilà et donc il nous leur
achète 500 francs la tonne la grande
nouveauté de cette association c'est que
c'est zéro franc zéro centime de frais
de fonctionnement zéro franc zéro
centime c'est à dire que même la banque
qui s'occupe des trucs elle prend rien
les mecs qui collecte les bouchons les
cds bigarchons j'en ai déjà 160 en
franchissant soit une big archamps dans
tous les départements
j'espère y joue un havre à 300 d'accord
et donc cédé mais quand un local où on
peut stocker 10 tonnes de bouchons sont
là le camion vient et les emmène d'eton
cinq mille balles ça fait à chaque fois
et si dominique voynet voulait bien me
les mettre dans le train par exemple
monique voynet sais que je gagnerai 850
baleines grises c'est parce qu'il ya 350
pages de transport ah ouais et donc si
on les mettait dans le train donc ça
serait bien on a téléphoné un coup mais
on est tombé sur un deuxième à 28e
couteau le charcutier du petit neveu à
dominique venait qui nous est dit que
c'était pas possible que je m'adresse
directement à l aile et pour le train
dans quelqu'un qu'elle nous donne des
trains pour mettre nos p'tits bouchons
et le pognon et vao et le pognon il va
en achètent des fauteuils way et on
achète des fauteuils on va faire des
bassines des sceaux pour l'afrique chez
les récipients sont très important dans
ma vie c'est une grosse cause de
mortalité 1 c'est la flotte que tu fais
cinq bornes pour y chercher de l'eau il
faut des récipients fallait qu on la
boit fallait cuisine on fait des tatras
a fini par laver les pieds du gamin et
on fait un orphelinat à madagascar
pour 60 gosse et c est tout ça sans
demander de pognon uniquement demandant
aux gens de faire un petit acteur génial
ce qui gêne c'est que c'est les enfants
qui portent cette association dont je
dis à tous les enfants de france qui
font ça je leur fais un gros bisou ce
que c'est eux qui disent non au moment
jette pas le bouchon les enfants sont
pas dans le monde de l'argent tu sais
donc c'est un moyen pour eux de faire un
acte tout d'un coup d'amour puisqu'ils
sont pas dans le monde du pognon et ça
permet même aux riches de données
monsieur le riche ici jamais quoi
d'autre
je marie apparemment votre petite
entreprise ne connaît pas la crise et
sur plan sexuel comment ça va très bien
ça va très très bien je suis normal
malgré tout c'est oui je le dit
d'ailleurs ne respecta il dit gd les
éjaculations sont moins forte au départ
ouais parce que c'est le premier jet
côté côté jeunes des fois tu arrives à
te le mettre dans le pays après en
vieillissant sarthon même du ve puis
après ça prend le gué époque sur la
basket c'est sur le bout en plastique de
la basket époque j'en ai entendu une
pizza à eux les toits pénétré par l'idée
ça va il gardait comme ça donc on va
faire la servio alain delon a on ne
bouge pas en danger d'une guerre on ne
bouge pas pendant le jingle à sa
reposent de bâtir alors est-ce que
légaliser les drogues douces ça vous
semble une idée stupéfiante où il vous
semble stupéfiants qu'on n'est pas déjà
fait alors là jean marie bigard pense
que
cote de toute façon tout le monde le
fait ouais ben ça changerait pas grand
chose en fait donc que tout le monde se
bat toujours pour la légalisation de
marijuana blanc fait c'est fait c'est ce
que vous y voilà à peu près à peu près
c'est ce que jean marie bigard pense oui
c'est ça redore excusez moi alors on va
passer maintenant au commerce du sexe
qui est un sujet qui est nouveau pour
vous est ce que vous êtes pour la
réouverture des maisons closes ou pour
la fermeture des boîtes à partouzes nom
alors je suis alors allé à l'un d'eux
[Applaudissements]
d'ailleurs lui marqué par sa pareille
pareil que pour la première question
rigueur et pour le cul existe tout bon
de pratiquer il ya des bordels
absolument partout et des quartiers
entiers de paris où il est possible
évidemment de deux squats et ça coûte
des fois un petit peu cher mais on boit
un verre avec une jeune fille à moitié
dénudée jean marie bigard l'a fait déjà
et
jean-marie via s'est aperçu que derrière
le petit rideau la bouteille de
champagne passé à 2500 balle il fallait
et qu'il fallait enfin en faire enfin
les en boire au moins 3 ou 4 avant de
jean marie pierre pense que c'est cher
est ce que jean marie bigard pense que
quand on va dans un endroit comme ça et
puis qu'on est derrière le rideau avec
la jeune fille dénudée et qu'on a bu
trois bouteilles de champagne on peut
encore la sauter la fille
jean marie bigard pense que c'est
emmerdant de se retrouver avec des
agriculteurs qui sont allés au salon wii
et puis
de trois quinquagénaires rouge aux
anciens de la cgt ils sont l'oeil
jean marie bigard s'est fait comme tout
le monde piégée ouais bien sûr parce que
jean marie bigard est arrivé à paris oui
jean marie bigard est passé devant et
d'innombrables le bar avec des jeunes
filles avec la moitié des niches en a
l'air et puis jean marie bigard est
rentré il est rentré l'a dit est ce que
je peux boire un verre et immédiatement
plusieurs jeunes filles se sont
représentés à lui alors que jean marie
bigard n'était pas connue encore qu'il
n'était pas jean marie bigard qu'est ce
que c'est maintenant donc jean marie
bigard s'est fait baiser la gueule comme
tout le monde mais c'est vrai que c'est
un endroit existe et donc sont ouverts
dont ils sont ouverts oui hélas il est
en fête
ça pourrait coûter moins cher bien oui
si on sorgues
si on s'organisait un peu jean marie
bigard est un petit peu déstabilisés par
par vos questions à gaza alors bon on va
passer à des choses plus simples jean
marie bigard votre conception du luxe
est ce que vous préférez boire du coca
cola dans un verre en cristal ou du
petrus dans un gobelet en plastique
jean marie bigard préfère le petrus quel
que soit le contenant je préfère boire
du petrus même dans un gobelet anglais
absolument d'accord
est ce que pour garder celle que vous
aimez vous êtes prêt à l'enfermer dans
un palais ou à la sortir dans des clubs
échangistes a donc on retourne dans le
club échangiste jean-marie peu non jean
marie bigard pense que l'enfermer dans
un palais évidemment c'est une solution
qui est très facile mais comme jean
marie bigard est un combattant jean
marie bigard peut éventuellement penser
qu à bout de souffle et s'il emmenait sa
femme d'un club échangiste je pense que
jamais avait garé sera un peu gêné de
voir peut-être sa femme se faire
pénétrer par le rouge au de la cgt tout
à l'heure et donc
jean marie bigard ça rappelle cette
blague et jean marie bigard gafsa et qui
dit à son pote ça te dirait de venir
dans une partouze dit ouais idiot serait
combien m'a dit si tu viens avec ta
femme en sera 3 bien qu'elle se montrer
plus choquant l'interdiction des
mariages homos ou la banalisation des
divorces hétéro ohlala jean marie bigard
est très choquée par cette question
c'est une originalité encore une fois
l'homosexualité c'est bien qu'elle soit
original donc il faut pas la mettre dans
un concept normal je me lance et puis de
nord banalisée banaliser les divorces
hétéros les divorces et héros bat jean
marie bigard pense que c'est déjà fait
on a pas mal d'analysés mais jamais un
bigard rossy pense encore une fois que
on se donne une bonne conscience en
déchirant fait un papier avec quelqu'un
mais je pense que le désengagement qu'on
a avec une personne de la de déchirer un
papier qui est un contrat de mariage ils
pensent que ce n'est pas une chose très
très jolie de toute façon et jean marie
bigard pense que
c'est mieux de rester sur ses positions
et jean marie bigard ne divorce pas
voilà je me rivière par exemple le
divorce par exemple va pas faire du
social est ce que vous augmentez les
salaires ou vous diminuerez le temps de
travail alors là jean marie bigard
voudrait dire un message à l'ensemble de
la planète
c'est que le travail en aura pas de plus
en plus y en a de moins en moins
l'erreur de moins en moins de travail
donc il faut se faire à l'idée qu'on
travaillera de moins en moins et donc et
vous
oui mais il faut se faire à l'idée qu'il
y aura une ce sera un luxe de travailler
et de dire on travaille pour l'ensemble
de la planète et toutes les grosses
entreprises qui travaillent avec des
machines qui ne sont pas syndiqués à la
cgt qu'il n'agit pas de banderole le
matin non mais on appuie sur un bouton
elles font de travail de dix personnes
dont il ya toujours de moins en moins de
travail les grosses entreprises vont
gagner de plus en plus d'argent et donc
il va falloir à un moment que nous on
s'occupe autrement que par le travail
peut être en s'occupant se sont faire
peut-être en s'occupant de son prochain
peut-être que on se spiritual ''sera
puisque c'est ce qui a été prédit par
tout le monde depuis des centaines
d'années
chanter avec sa présente pas si
longtemps
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il n'a jamais entendu 400 personnes dans
un achat chanter le home qui est le seul
à la barre et le son de l'univers et
c'est magnifique c'est le seul son qui
qui qu'on devrait entendre chaque fois
qu'on a un peu de repos on peut leur
faire pendant l'émission quand ça tourne
vers son soin way intérieure et je
propose qu'on fasse pour la mission
comme ça certains nombres de pose
absolument un je pouvais me faire penser
au régime c'est pas trop mon truc dans
ce fait pas rigueur n'aime pas quand
vous vous foutez de la gueule
bien alors jean marie un gars qu'avez
vous le sentiment d'avoir le plus
souvent ratés dans votre vie votre
chance d'être un ou d occasion de la
fermer
jean marie bigard ne rate pas de chance
il ne rate pas de train non plus jean
marie bigard est à l'heure tout le temps
il ne rate pas le train le train attend
jean marie bigard et jean marie bigard
jean mabire pour ce qui est de fermer sa
gueule la mère aurait eu des occasions
de fermer sa gueule mais il a pensé que
ce serait dommage pour l'ensemble des
êtres humains de la planète qui
attendent l'avis de jean marie bigard
là
[Musique]
allah
et maintenant mesdames messieurs
maintenant
qui pesé dans jet set et avec son
prochain film ça risque bien de
continuer il a choisi
champs elysées voici lover wilson
[Applaudissements]
c'est vraiment mère savoir personnes
messieurs mais vous avez pu la petite
barbe comme dans le film parce que dans
le film il a une petite mignon ouais ça
va j'ai ma vie va changer ma vie a
changé bientôt parce qu'il ya c'est mes
yeux se sont ouverts
enfin la jetée à fait alors justement
dans france soir est déclarée en 98 je
commence à mai mais un peu je perds
quelques inhibitions j'ai moins peur de
me lâcher et finalement je m'en fous ça
vous a réussi finalement et puis je
repars en arrière ouais je commence à
nouveau avoir peur je commence à voir
comment ça non non non c'est vrai que
quand on voit que vous êtes mis là
depuis thierry sabot d'accord plus beau
blond je suis fatigué
ouais
non mais c'est vrai que
vous
[Musique]
et en même temps là je pensais bien là
mais d'imaginer que nous cellulaire
imaginez que nos cellules nerveuses ne
connaîtront plus l'avant lalanne à ses
fines dos je vivrai oui c'est déjà trop
tard
c'est trop tard c'est table la mer non
serment voilà l'essentiel des chansons
qui tue donc je disais après jet set
donc votre nouveau film s'appelle h
est-ce pour hors service et un film de
jean paul lilienfeld
alors je vais faire le pitch ah ah oui
depuis j'ai fait refaire le pitch mais
non mais vous pouvez corriger si je me
trompe c'est cinq tueurs à gages si les
bras cassés des mecs c'est vraiment des
mauvais coups que le dsq the web alors
vous vous êtes le chef françois berléand
c'est le doyen stéphane guérin tillié
c'est l'homme de main lorànt deutsch
l'apprenti il ya dieudonné dieudonné
dans la femme est joué par claudia
gerini alors lui sont sur le point de
repère ce sont sa seule certitude dans
la vie c'est sa femme et elle elle ne
croit en fait lui les tueurs à gages
mais le croit vrp dans une boîte de
chaussures et quand elle découvre la
vérité il ya une altercation entre
dieudonné sa femme donc un peu violent
un peu violente et il lui met un coup de
poing par réflexe professionnel
tellement l'habitude mais un coup de
poing et elle tombe dans le coma il est
effondré lui de voir ce à quoi elle va
pas se réveiller et ils commencent à se
mettre dans la tête que si il se rachète
finalement elle va se réveiller parce
qu'elle lui donne des signes depuis son
commun dès qu'il a le réflexe de vouloir
bafé quelqu'un ou de le tuer
effectivement elle fait marcher la
machine dans la dans l'hôpital pour
prouver qu'elle va elle va y passer
voilà qui comprends qu'effectivement il
doit se changer son sa façon forte
qu'elle vive war lviv c'est beau
commencer par celle est enceinte on lui
veut quitter le métier dieudonné et il
commence par sauver ces deux prochaines
victimes qui sont interprétés par jacky
boyer et catherine boucher voilà et
l'employeur c'est vous qui êtes le chef
vous n'êtes pas d'accord et vous lancer
à tous ses anciens collègues à ses
trousses d'une certaine façon mais parce
qu'il est détenteur de secrets il
connaît les secrets du métier ici ou est
planqué l'oseille et puis
et puis voilà il faut l'éliminer quoi la
scène le départ c'est une espèce de pulp
fiction française est rigolo bien
bah oui parce qu'en fait c'est vraiment
des pieds nickelés c'est vrai que ils
sont tous obsédés par quelque chose
alors je parlais du poil tout à l'heure
effectivement c'est parce que mon
personnage est particulièrement obsédé
par lui-même il est trés narcisse et il
passe son temps à se raser à se couper
le moindre poil etc
ils ont tous une obsession les émissions
télé tamagoshi le magot chi série télé
séries télé la retraite pour berléand et
c'est ça qui est assez touchant dans le
film est assez drôle et original c'est
qu'effectivement ça ne va jamais où on
croit que ça va aller c'est une comédie
drôle et mais en même temps policière et
un temps x comme ils sont ils sombrent
ans qui sont ils sont des accès ils sont
voilà c'est ça l'originalité du film
c'est qu'ils nous surprennent à chaque
fois par par leurs obsessions en fait
voilà je veux absolument mais je me suis
amusé il faut m'excuser de vous déranger
nous avons une nouvelle extraordinaire
pour nous oui j'ai regardé vivant il est
parmi nous java est parmi nous je fais
quoi
tueur à gages
[Musique]
ces mioches s ils shootent encore une
fois ma femme m eur matic cet effet
n'est pas faire notre part est il s'est
mis hs mais pas marchand
bonjour à nozay la chambre de madame
marchand madame marchand c'est la d103
je connais tout madame marchand c'est là
qu'elle s'était une élue alors vous
allez prendre entre ne sont pas capables
pour des jets j'ai une formation
commerciale c'est tout
ok et qu'un maire de même pas de
conversation entre deux shoots isced nos
petits cons je suis un sale con est une
vraie [ __ ] et je fais dans mon froc et
je fais dans mon froc
est-ce que ça se voit que j'ai une
perruque
non seulement personne peut le voir
comment tu fais pour entrée unique c'est
la gueule avec une bombe
c'était hs de jean paul lilienfeld a pas
mal mais c'est vachement bien
on est debout alors je vais dire les
sondages et des médias une toujours bien
sûr comme le 13 le 13 ouais non mais
attends pour vous c'est extraordinaire
bien la personne qu'ils ont adoré dans
jet set
ils vont retrouver le même type d'acteur
c'est comme ça que les gens j'ai trouvé
vraiment génial merci
c'est vrai qu'en tout cas ça même je
crois que j'ai mis vingt ans quoi à
pouvoir en faire on va en parler mais
d'abord comme vous êtes quand même très
très polymorphe
vous êtes quand même metteur en scène de
théâtre cet été quand même un vrai comme
le fils de georges wilson
alors on va faire pomme parce que j'ai
oublié je me rends compte que j'ai
oublié on va faire deux fois une fois
pour le film et une fois pour le théâtre
puisque jean lambert
voilà c'était bien de mes parents
maintenant vous avez le refaire pour le
théâtre des deux ânes pour le thé
j'avais une idée peut-être qu'on pourra
en faire comme ça un stock au début de
l'émission
oui à comme ça approche très tranquille
on les ferait tous au début ou à la fin
mais c'est bien je trouve que c'est
honnête comme procéder parce
qu'effectivement on vient pour ça ouais
et donc pourquoi pas se plier la foule
dire non moi je crois que les gens là tu
étais bien jamais quand il fonde la
promo mois la fin du spectacle dit merci
pour l'argent ouais bah oui j'aurais les
gens le disent jamais sur le jury a
écrit si vous achetez ce bouquin vous
aller claquer 98 from a par exemple
s'est étonné bien alors on va faire la
promo mais là comme on va en parler
parce que c'est pas mal d'histoires
c'est la quatorzième estivales de
perpignan dont qui dure du 30 juin au 30
juillet et les 7 8 et 9 juillet au
palais des rois de majorque à perpignan
il ya votre première mise en scène de
théâtre s'adhérer nice et les
avant-premières de racines mais sissoko
avoue que je posais la question non plus
au cas où j'ai oublié un effet team
américaine à bérénice de racine avec
kristin scott thomas et didier sandre
donc voilà c'est bien non on va aussi
est là festival au festival d'avignon où
on va jouer j'ai pas une dizaine de fois
et on revient à l'automne au palais de
chaillot l'envers c'est quoi le pitch de
bérénice pitch il est très simple c'est
la séparation tragique entre la reine
bérénice et l'empereur titus titus et
obliger le magnifique didier sandre il
est obligé de renoncer à cet amour son
bonheur intime parce que on dit que
c'est parce que c'est la raison d'état
l'as rome qui interdit que ce soit une
reine qui puissent devenir la les
poussins empereur surtout parce qu'en
fait comme les hommes politiques comme
les hommes en général et c'est ça le
vrai sens de la pièce il a besoin de se
construire une idée un peu abstraite
c'est à dire la politique le pouvoir le
règne et que d'une certaine façon ils
sacrifient l'amour son bonheur à une
idée ou une idée abstraite voilà bel est
obligé de partir donc les 7 8 et 9
juillet à perpignan au palais des rois
de majorque ensuite avignon à partir 17
juillet suite à chaillot et maintenant
on va parler d'eux
m
bon vous dites je n'ai pas voulu être
acteur pour de bonnes raisons j'ai voulu
être acteur pour les paillettes c'est
vrai qu'au début à 13 ans vous avez
voulu être acteur parce que vous
accompagnez votre père georges wilson
dont les premières au départ c'était
juste l'amour du spectacle plus elle
avance à j'espère qu'il ya jingle triste
vraiment poignant parce que rsa quand on
m'a demandé à l'école si je voulais être
comédien j'ai dis surtout pas surtout
pas parce qu'elle comédien c'est
quelqu'un qui ait jamais à la maison
ouais et donc ça c'était c'était
vraiment surtout ça le truc le cauchemar
c'était un comédien s'était forcément
quelqu'un qui était tellement obsédé par
son travail et que toute façon il était
il y avait le temps pour rien d'autre
c'est vrai que votre père vous le voyez
pas beaucoup a été levée la campagne
voulons non mais il était là il était
quand même ils regardent l'émission il
faut pas que je dise des choses et nous
avons des rapports
nous avons des rapports mai mais ils
sont treize années en touriste et la
campagne non non non nos médias
alors votre père donc justement c'est
georges wilson qui était saxophoniste
c'est des gens ne savent pas ils croient
qu'il a toujours été comédien qui a pris
l'été acteur puis directeur du tnp
évidemment et votre prénom lambert vient
de la pièce de claudel oui alors votre
maire ben elle vient comme lui
d'ailleurs comme georges wilson d'un
milieu assez modeste était très belle
votre mère elle est ce qu'elle voulait
le mannequin elle voulait être
comédienne mêlée puis à 17 ans elle a
rencontré votre père est devenu femme au
foyer parce que lui comme il avait été
orphelin il voulait recréer une cellule
familiale
oui c'est vrai que on oublie tout le
temps quand on apparaît dans le métier
que lui public imagine que tout est fait
d' avance pour vous parce que c'est
voilà vous êtes déjà dans le faste des
seins que vous venez d'un milieu
j cl et c est pour mon père c'est vrai
qu'être acteur comme pour beaucoup
d'acteurs maintenant c'est une vengeance
contre le monde une vengeance contre
l'injustice contre la misère contre la
guerre contre tous alors effectivement
moi j'arrive plus tard plus protégés
mais néanmoins avec mes souffrances
alors vous voyez souvenir c'est à
chaillot ouais au palais des papes
d'avignon aussi et vous dites mon père
incarné des personnages de roy qui
régnait sur des sur des châteaux et
j'avais le sentiment que ces châteaux
étaient à nous mais surtout chaillou moi
c'est pendant des années quand on
passait devant le trocadéro le palais de
chaillot 11 ans ouais mais que c'était
notre château et qui en erythrée oui bah
oui parce que forcément il était en plus
endroits à l'intérieur et que tout le
monde faisait un petit peu la lettre au
fait j'ai déchanté à l'école vous
mentiez vous disiez que vous alliez
passer des week end à new york vous
aviez des rolls tout ça j'ai passé
longtemps dans ma vie a menti doit
effectivement j'avais une sorte de
fantasme du effectivement delà du faste
c'est curieux parce qu'en plus on
manquait de rien vraiment au moment où
moi je suis arrivé finalement et ouais
je vais penser que notre vie ne
suffisait pas et c'est un moteur très
régulier chez les acteurs effectivement
il faut on veut devenir prince alors le
premier choc artistique c'est à l'âge de
7 ans c'est au palais des papes avec
votre mère une couverture sur les genoux
et ciel du mistral
et puis vous êtes tombé convaincre
vachement elle raconte berlin
vous tombez amoureux delaunay bellon
dans l'illusion comique de corneille ce
coup ci et puis vous tombez complètement
amoureux d'elle vous dit je veux la
revoir le lendemain je veux la revoir je
veux la revoir et lendemain vous le
découvrez durant les répétitions
pas maquillée transpirant au soleil dans
la cour du palais des papes
et là c'est une tragédie pour mais ce
que je demande où elle est faite s'il
avait oui elle était dans le costume
jeudi met en avant des mois la bonne
quoi et là je crois que de toute façon
levée des limites du théâtre mais tombée
d'un coup à 7 ans sur les épaules mais
c'est trop tôt ouais un peu trop tout
récemment ce cas c'est que le théâtre
c'est aussi le syli la vie des femmes
tout ça je me suis vous inquiétez pas je
me suis permis
voulez vous allongez vous en parlerons
ici de s'allonger dans le divan
catherine sûrement ici alors présidence
vous n'êtes pas entré dans la profession
par votre père mais par deux profs de
français
et puis après votre père vous donner de
petits rôles mais quand il a vu que
c'était sérieux
justement il a dit je suis pas d'accord
parce que t'as pas assez souffert
justement je lui avais eu effectivement
cette vengeance de l'orphelin la guerre
un george hill a dit qu'il n'a pas assez
similaire au solaire
voilà la magie fait des révélations
absolument pas plus ils s'étaient
carrément autour d'une conversation
super prix incroyables il y avait un
micro soir et je pense que c'était
surtout pour me mettre en garde contre
et je continue à vouloir mettre en garde
moi même les générations de gens qui
veulent faire ce métier c'est vrai qu'on
en prend plein la gueule c'est vrai qu'
on est toujours en première ligne
critiqué sur non pas un travail qu'ont
fourni mais sur des qualités soin de sa
chair soit de son caractère et du coup
on n'a aucune protection on est
perpétuellement jugé sur qui on est et
c'est horriblement brésil ça va là que
votre père vous dis c'est pas en même
temps c'est vrai il avait un peu raison
vous un métier d'acteur ça se construit
sur la souffrance sur la vengeance plus
que mais plus que son modèle sympa les
autres je pense que parfois j'avais
passé mois de moteurs de mai
j'ai trouvé en cours de route ouais ce
moteur la lancée d'un tel désir de faire
du théâtre du cinéma de jouer que vous
partez à londres au drama center et ses
quelque temps plus tard vous faites
votre premier film ça c'est un coup de
bol alors j'ai vraiment de la chance où
il fait giulia de fred zinnemann jane
fonda est votre religion de tournage
vous retrouver comme ça nez à nez avec
le le regard bleu turquoise de jane
fonda et c'est vrai non non mais c'est
génial parce que j'ai plus rien à dire
est ce que j'allais dire mais oui
justement ca river song et son regard
bleu turquoise voilà ce que je veux dire
quand même ses gains alors vous oubliez
le rôle de quelqu'un qui était mort de
peur et vous étiez mort de peur j'ai
tracée pour lui passer pour un génie aux
yeux jean mas mais effectivement cinq
ans plus tard il m'a proposé un rôles
principaux de son film qui s'appelait
cinq jours ce printemps là aux côtés de
sean connery parce qu'il avait trouvé
que j'avais été tellement incroyable
dans cette scène où j'étais simplement
je vais vraiment faisait dans mon
pantalon
il a été il a été vraiment émerveillé
mais la peur on pourrait en parler parce
que c'est vrai que moi j'ai quand
j'étais petit je cherchais cette
sensation en permanence je voulais avoir
peur dans les manèges etc et
curieusement j'ai la peur elle est
présente et c'est une c'est une vraie
drogue et c'est un supporte pas et en
même temps on a peur quand on aimerait
vous par exemple ça gratte d'avoir peur
justement c'est la volonté de la peur
vous aimez avoir peur des lipper bah oui
c'est vrai que c'est un moteur
formidable ici l'an 2000 personnes trop
dans les institutions
oui mais c'est le cette peur a été
compensée par ya enfin en tout cas moi
je ressens deux choses c'est que j'ai
envie un peu de me barrer en courant
mais je crois que je donnerai ma place a
personne pour rien au monde je me disais
est ce que je me dis que j'ai très très
peur je me dis j'imagine un copain qui
me dit bon on va se fait rien laisse
tomber vient à temps mettez conques
voilà donc cinq jours ce printemps-là de
fred zinnemann cinq ans après
effectivement giulia et là vous faites
un suisse et une copine qui vous dit
d'aller au casting déguisé en suisse
ouais il se trouvait en était au mois de
juin il fait super chaud à paris chez
rivera quénard je suais comme maintenant
et et on m'a demandé quel temps il vit à
paris j'ai dit
il neigeait neiges on avait en droit
dans les yeux et j'ai senti que c'était
assez de secondes que j'ai eu le rôle
voilà maintenant deux fois de suite
ouais exil man quelques jours plus tard
vous retrouvez face à sean connery et là
vous avez le sentiment d'usurper vous
dit c'est pas possible vont s'apercevoir
que que je mérite pas d'être là bas
comme maintenant à elle maintenant dans
cette émission comme maintenant sur
scène à chaque moment à un moment donné
on se dit mais ils vont bien découvrir
que l'on est on concède pas du tout de
quoi on parle on est pas mais yvan
gagnent ils vont bien découvrir alors
particulièrement dans cette espèce de
montagne et que 16 qui vous qui vous
toise comme ça et qui fait aucun effort
avec le regard avec l'école des sources
y est
ça a été cinq mois mais vraiment serré
les dents ou je pleurais tous les soirs
dans mon hôtel parce que j'en prenais
plein à pois alors ensuite vous
retourner en france il avoue commencer
votre carrière cinématographique avec la
boum 2 été chinés avec brooke à la
vouivre film de georges wilson est là
[Musique]
la génisse aller là plein des disques de
vous j'en ai trouvé plein il y en a des
très bons ou chanter très bien mais les
classiques et tous ces flux ça vous a
pris un moment ça faisait du cinéma deux
films magazine man la boum 2 tout ça et
puis d'un coup est parti je crois que
c'est cette fibre familiale le père
c'est que ce feu ni son frère est un
saxophoniste des boeufs votre père avec
votre je pense que d'une certaine façon
peut-être que au lieu d'être acteur
j'aurais dû faire de la musique et c'est
ma façon de faire d'amis qui s'est
arrêté de faire du chant ouais mais moi
j'ai monsieur exposé sans assez de
préparation d'être revenu vers le cinéma
ce moment là non mais je n'avais jamais
arrêté de signer vrai oui mais là
sérieusement parce qu'en plus c'est ce
truc en france qui est que si on chante
c'est forcément votre carrière de pas
très bien et donc c'est une à ses dépens
car pas très bien c'est un one shot
celui du mas d'agenais une mais bien
mais bien les ravines qui joue
moyennement mais voilà on va faire leur
faire un petit test
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[ __ ] parce que ça se danse forcément
moins bien donc le 13 juin qu'est ce qui
se passe est très sera le 13 juin à la
sortie de la comédie hs avec dieudonné
et françois berléand lavalas et toute la
combe du fait de la promo là
alors donc lambert wilson quand vous
étiez petit vous croyez que vous étiez
un prince et votre père en roi bon on va
voir ce à quoi vous croyez aujourd'hui
on va faire l'interview croyance en
ébauche bas pendant les vosges pendant
les jean galle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non non non il a bougé au début mais
après il sait que ninon il s'est repris
maintenant très bien on est des cas pas
baffie ça valait pas de problème bien
lambert wilson est ce que vous croyez en
vous pas beaucoup vous commencé quand
même c'est un peu là c'est un peu là
c'est un peu moment des forêts est ce
que vous croyez en dieu
ça c'est une question mais beaucoup plus
personnel que les questions de sexe je
trouve que c'est une question à laquelle
je voudrais pas répondre parce que je
veux c'est incroyablement privé comme
question je suis je suis croyant et je
n'aime pas la religion est ce que vous
croyez au mauvais esprit oui surtout
dans les théâtres
je me méfie énormément de me moquer des
des esprits qui habitent dans les
théâtres parce que ils se vengent
pratiquement à chaque fois si vous
arrivez
dites moi c'est pas terrible et qu'il ya
toujours un truc qui va vous tomber sur
la gueule à un moment donné faut faire
je m'en méfie terriblement sur les sur
les esprits un jeu je brûle de l'encens
dans tout les seuls où je joue surtout
avec de l'encens pour abaisser le
collier technicien arrivé dit ils nous
disent ici là il ya des petits et des
diablotins parce qu'on a des emmerdes
depuis ce matin je brûle de l'encens
dans toute la salle
mais je fais sérieusement vous croyez au
père noël non je crois à jean marie
bigard depuis ce mardi vers adore c'est
ce que vous êtes
est ce que vous croyez au sexe sans
amour
oui oui j'y suis et l'amour sans sexe
bien sûr encore plus bas encore plus
mauvais parce que je pense que peut-être
le vrai amour le vrai amour ne se situe
pas du tout au niveau du sexe est ce que
vous croyez que les drogues douces amène
aux drogues dures
non non par expérience je peux vous dire
que non vous croyez à la mort d'elvis
s'est dit c'est là qu'il était mardi
cette posture n'amène pas forcément aux
drogues douces rester aux drogues dures
c'est une question de volonté que vous
croyez à l'effet des crèmes antirides
est-ce que j'en suis pas la preuve est
ce que vous croyez la fidélité j'espère
en la fidélité ouvrions céline dion je
vis par céline est vrai que cette
interview est terminée j'espère que non
abc
faisant preuve
bon
et maintenant et maintenant
[Applaudissements]
kla voulait
[Musique]
et jean-marie une seule patte je suis un
con un petit bisou
clara morgane bonsoir j'ai 20 ans vous
mesurer à m 65 vous peser 52 kg et vous
venez de remporter à cannes le hot d'or
de la meilleure starlette française
voilà voilà mesdames messieurs
est-ce que
comment ça s'est passé ni pour la
meilleure star les français sont
quelques coeurs qui battent la chamade
les nominés sont fiona sulymka zia
estelle laurence mendy leone clara
morgane sophie roche et asian challes et
le gagnant est
[Musique]
ce que si
pourquoi
[Musique]
m
je suis que si
[Musique]
mais en chine
je me croyais être enfouis mer je
voudrais remercier déjà toutes les
personnes sans qui je ne serais pas là
greg santoro fred coppula bluwan tous
ces gens ce que je voulais dire
pour une fois que je veux tous vous voir
parce que vous ne connaissez pas encore
bien ce que ça fait pas longtemps je
suis avec vous je suis très fier
aujourd'hui d'être d'être devant bourg
je suis très heureuse ce que je voulais
dire c'est que j'ai envie de donner une
belle image c'est la pornographie j'ai
envie que que ce soit beau et c'est pour
ça que je choisis mes partenaires j'ai
envie de faire avec tellement d'émotion
[Musique]
s
les usa le cas cette année
oui mais voilà alors vous avez déclaré
je trouve formidable que des actrices de
x est aujourd'hui la possibilité d'aller
donner leur avis dans des émissions de
télévision et dans les magazines bien
nous aussi gens fous bon alors vous avez
fait un seul film vous êtes déjà une
star non mon deuxième film est sorti le
1er juin
ro donc il s'appelle la collectionneuse
et voilà si on décide alors pourquoi
c'est devenu une star aussi dit pas si
vous n'êtes pas les les sourcils trop
maquillée pas les seins refaits c'est ça
je pense que on se faisait une serre on
se fait une certaine image de la
pornostar quand on dit et moi j'ai gardé
mon image et ça étonne pas mal de palal
de pas mal de monde donc c'est peut-être
une raison et je répondais à ce que les
gens attendent et peut-être non une un
peu femme enfant peut-être une personne
qu'on peut croiser dans la rue qui peut
être n'importe qui pas forcément
quelqu'un destiné pour ça qu'à
travailler pendant des années j'arrive
j'essaie d'être naturel j'aime pas mon
image et ça a l'air de marcher j'ai mis
mes lunettes
alors votre premier film c'était un
projet x avec fred coppula le
réalisateur fred coppula le deuxième la
collectionneuse j'imagine c'est aussi
avec fred coppula
je vous ai signé pour trois films avec
lui bien plus est signé pour trois films
et on travaillera je pense toujours
ensemble parce qu'au-delà de du métier
on est devenus de très grands années il
est devenu une sorte de grand frère
alors contrairement contrairement à
rafael anderson qui était assise et
votre place et quelques semaines vient
de publier hard chez grasset qui marche
très très bien d'ailleurs
vous n'êtes pas encore déçu par le
métier à vous parce que j'ai connu
raphaël en 95 elle était un peu comme
vous ai trouvé ça formidable maintenant
là c'est à dire que j'ai fait dans des
conditions qui sont très particulières
voilà je suis consciente de ce à quoi
vous dites je fais du bien à la
pornographie qu'armand plaisir se voit
dans mes yeux
oui j'espère en tout cas faire du bien à
pornographie au début c'était pas mon
objectif je suis arrivé comme ça pour
m'amuser et plus plus ça va que je me
sens bien dans ma position et j'ai envie
de lui faire du bien en même temps
vouloir le monde du golf a vu comme
sernam alors ce qu'il faut dire c'est
que clara a une particularité elle ne
tourne qu'avec un seul partenaire
masculin c'est son mec
ces grecs santoro vous aurez qu avec lui
ben disons que à la base j'avais comme
objectif de tourner avec des personnes
dont j'avais envie donc forcément je
tourne avec mon ami et je dis pas que je
tournerai jamais avec personne d'autre
mais en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est tu
tomberas avec des personnes en géant oui
parce que c'est nécessaire pour moi lui
tourne avec d'autres filles oui vous
dites je sais que dans sa tête
quand et avec les autres c'est vraiment
un travail oit sur la leyre ignorons
c'est à dire que je sais que par fun
qu'il aime c'est moi je sais que si la
direction s'est pas non plus par hasard
mais comme teurs j'entendais la question
que vous avez posé je pense qu'il ya
contre le sexe sans amour existe mais ça
c'est autre chose
faire un film c'est pas comme si on
faisait l'amour pour de vrai
sans arrêt des coupures je veux dire
c'est faut être sur un tournage pour
comprendre ce qu'est un tournage quand
même c'est pas cette folie pour les
hommes de parce qu'il faut quand même
qu'ils gardent la gaule tout le temps il
ya des coupures
que deviennent coupe ultra tendance met
à 6h30
ces pourparlers par les performances
agen un copain on connaît plein de gens
dans le cinéma et qui ont qui l'aurait
arrivé de tourner dans des films ou de
travailler dans des films comme ça
x et il disait que les comédiens ce
astiquer le menhir tout le temps qu'ils
arrivaient à garder la gaule pendant des
heures et des heures c'est une journée
c'est une sacrée performance y est le
coup de chapeau c'est le vieux moi je
trouve qu'ils sont trop
moi j'aimerais bien de temps en temps
qu'il mette un mec normal dans la bande
parce que parce qu'ils apprennent aux
femmes un nouvel disent ah bah oui mais
sur la cassette c'était plus gros c'est
boulot forcément cd cd des cieux
d'élevage quand même parce que moi
j'aimerais bien moi à la maison je bats
je la prends moi quand je la prends
comme ça j'en vois encore un bout un
guide et bassin mais moi et si je mets
deux mains moi je vois plus rien ouais
y'a encore celles qui dépassent c'est
normal ça
[Applaudissements]
mais cette loi va bien bien bien là ça
c'est fait alors lorsque le vélo donc
l'accent taureau il tourne avec d'autres
filles vous vous pensez donc
effectivement quand et avec elle celle
et que du travail
elle vous l'a dit toute façon et si vous
vous proposer de tourner avec une énorme
star du porno comme rocco par exemple
c'est pas ce genre de propositions qui
m'intéresserait c'est de toute façon
c'est moi qui ferai la démarche tant
parlement réalisateur dans la mesure où
un acteur me plairait jours a envie de
tourner avec lui c'est assez difficile à
croire mais c'est la réalité qu'une
question de quoi de g pot 2 et
d'attirance comme on a dans la vie on
était des personnes qui sont différentes
des autres
oui les chèques avec d'échangé pour pour
votre amie clara c'est évidemment plus
facile pour lui et à digérer je suis au
travail s'il te plaît ne m'appelle pas
je dirais que je suis au bureau et c'est
vrai qu'il a aucune raison non mais
sérieusement il aucune raison de ne pas
être amoureux doués ou de vous quitter
puisque dans la mesure vous tout tout
tout va bien c'est dire le charcutier du
coin lui si jamais il a embrassé la
boulangère en cachette derrière l'église
s'il se fait gauler c'est l'horreur et
la dyle qu'est ce tu fais chérubins je
bosse
je rentrerai vers 7h dans cet art parce
qu'on a encore 2 ou bien la bonne idée
cela grave c'est exactement ça alors vos
parents beaux-parents maintenant auprès
de vos parents vous dites avec mes
parents j'ai préféré jouer franc jeu
c'est mieux qu'ils ont vu la cassette
chez auchan et en même temps alors
quelques mois auparavant vous aviez déjà
à vous et à votre mère votre bisexualité
oui mais voilà ben c'était pas trop
longtemps en vain mais elle m'avait
parlé de quelque chose et moi je lui ai
dit bon il faut que je te parle de moi
parce que bon il ya des choses que tu
sais pas et c'est vrai que j'ai une
attirance qui vers les femmes
elle m'a dit qu'elle s'en doutait un peu
parce que c'est vrai que depuis que je
suis jeune j'ai beaucoup de copines
m'ont elles sont toutes jolies on sait
pas pourquoi
donc voilà mais julia vous et
sincèrement et c'est vrai que quand on a
eu cette proposition pour monter sur
paris et tout ce à quoi je dédie aussi
directement ainsi qu'à mon père c'est
vrai qu'ils n'ont pas très bien pris
c'est normal il on prêterait que soient
vos quatre quelque chose comme ça mais
bon au fur et à mesure du temps le
barreau est pas loin non plus
messieurs
alors est ce que greg était avec vous
quand vous êtes allé voir vos pas on est
descendus ensemble on leur a dit ils ont
pas compris
normal mais on leur a expliqué à
montreux et après ils ont compris alors
attendez si vos parents vous aviez dit
ce jour-là écoute clara ont le plus de
voir je n'aurais jamais fait vous auriez
arrêter le porno c'est bien mais mes
parents même trop pour ça et ce qu'ils
veulent c'est que chaleureuse ouais je
pose la question mais part entière oui
mais profitez-en qui va il sait que je
subis soient bien quoi c'est tout et
aujourd'hui vous parler encore et votre
mère au téléphone vous appelé deux fois
par an une fois tous les deux jours on
est obligé de garder ce contact
elles sont à votre voix vous êtes
heureuse que tout va bien oui elle est
montée sur paris je suis descendu très
peu de temps sur marseille mais dans
l'entourage vos parents il ya des gens
qui leur disent ils dans ta fille
l'horreur pour c'est l'enfer parce que
je fais quelques chez pas mal de télé
quand même ce mois ci je fais cinq
couvertures de magazines je suis quand
même assez médiatisé pour une fille du x
et c'est vrai que c'est un énorme poids
pour eux quand même moi j'ai même
l'impression de m'être défilé en venant
sur paris et de leur avoir un petit peu
imposé sa et c'est ça qui me gêne c'est
le regard des autres j'ai eu une enfance
heureuse à une adolescence plutôt libre
non mes parents ça c'est un petit peu
froissé à mon adolescence parce que moi
j'avais besoin de liberté de sortir avec
mes copines le soir tout ça et ça ça a
été très difficile
je suis pas sorti tout seul il a fallu
que je rencontre greg et vous aviez
saison et que mes parents vrai qu'on
soit bien semble qu'ils aient confiance
en lui pour me laisser sortir et tout ça
alors vous vous prépariez un bts action
commerciale 8 et fonctionnaires greg
donc quoi après à la poste
c'est le facteur et voilà
comme d'habitude sonne toujours deux
fois je n'ai pas rencontré dans ce genre
de serre et alors vous alliez faire du
naturisme au cap d'agde ça c'était deux
ans après votre or m c'est moi qui avais
envie d'essayer parce que moi je
connaissais qu'à travers les bouquins de
films de rabat legs de houellebecq etc
mais non vraiment je parle du cap d'agde
de kara je parie que j'étais une pintade
j'aimerais y aller c'est très sympa
c'est très sympa et j'en sens très
simple avec des envoyés dès cet été ou
presque normalement oui j'aime aussi
beaucoup d'amis là bas après pompéi
boisset ouais ok ce qui se passe au cap
d'agde parce que les gens savent pas
tous
alors il ya un camping il ya des hôtels
pour ceux qui veulent pas vivre tout nu
tout le temps et c'est vrai que le soir
il ya des boîtes un petit peu
particulière échangiste commandiez et on
y va ou pas oui mais dans la journée par
exemple sur la plage de supermarché ça
baise moi non pas du tout non non il ya
un mélange au cap d'agde de de pureté de
gens avec le naturisme voyez toute cette
culture et d'autres qui sera pour les
gens qui prétendent exercer mon thermos
éviter du marché de prendre un blonde et
les couilles de
de prendre un autre melon avec ça
montrait enfin côté nature et que je
mangeais plus que c'est le rêve de c'est
un peu le rêve de tout le monde de
passer communiste c'est un monde à part
c'est un petit peu ça me fait penser à
l'époque des orgies romaines tout le
monde fait qu'ils voulaient mais jamais
personne n'est forcé on fait ce qu'on
veut quand on en a envie
c'est génial moi c'est la partie qui me
plaît c'est qu'on peut ne pas le seul
oui directement
ah non ça ce serait vraiment ça ce
serait le contraire de la liberté
commence alors pour vos vingt ans oui
grec vous invite à paris quiz pour
retrouver des amis du cap d'agde
ouais et alors là vous arrivez au salon
autre vidéo pour voir des copains de
quoi on est montés pour aller au salon
de vidéos parce qu'en s'intéressaient de
près ou de loin à ce milieu et on
voulait aussi voir paris une espèce de
vocations comme déjà chez vous pas
forcément
je pense la vocation c'était au niveau
de l'esprit libre et une certaine
ouverture d'esprit je pense c'était là
et c'est ce jour là où on a rencontré
fred coppula d'elisa terre qui est des
boules c'est lequel il y en a regardé
paris cinq minutes
alger où le pad c'est exactement ça on
n'a pas du tout plu paris alors quand on
vous parle du sexe vous dites vous
demande ce que vous pourrez faire des
bandes sexe vous dites je préfère rien
j'aime tout petit pas vraiment si c'est
vrai à oui à des trucs qui me pèse pas
dans le budget papa détail y'a n'ont pas
de détails pas forcément il ya une
fraude en particulier qui ne me plaît
pas vraiment mais à part ça j'aime
j'aime pas une chose en particulier
parce que ce serait ses limites et
j'aime un ensemble de choses au niveau
de la sexualité le bien les différentes
ambiances et on vous dit certains jours
j'aime bien d'être happé par surprise
puisque toujours attaché à cet effet
greg vie et les bandes et les yeux non
j'aime bien les deux côtés oui j'aime
bien jouer
oui vous aimez fred coppula j'ai
beaucoup suivi sa carrière
j'ai cru que je trouve que mademoiselle
a quand même un plan de carrière si ça
rigole pas c'est quand même pas je
gagnais vous hier maria l'annoncé est
bien là vous savez qu'on ne bouge pas
pendant le jingle en et bouge pas
pendant les ting on ne bouge pas pendant
les finales bien ça c'est fait
alterview voit bien fois premier
souvenir
ma première fois à tout de suite ça
parle de sexe j'y pense mais ça aurait
pu être sympa moi vite avant 13 ans vous
avez commencé tard en plus 15 ans et
demi je dois dire premier choc de votre
vie comme il ya tellement du sexe non ya
pas longtemps ce qu'avec un membre de ma
famille
je veux me suis retenu et
je vais me gêner premier mensonge il n'a
pas duré longtemps c'est une tromperie
le trompe et vague
oui bon mais ça a duré deux jours que
j'ai dit je vais jouer
on est déçus il a fait avant moi
cisco a fait son premier péché la
gourmandise secret première main non
papa ouais premier coup de foudre
greg greg ce greg quand même premier
baiser sans la langue la langue c'était
tort ah bon j'ai commencé avec la langue
j'avais déjà mon mac comme indice magois
t attend des choses c'était en quatrième
q vous aviez quatrième pas quel âge
non
simplifions la maison est alors
maintenant ils arrivent et avec la
langue avec la langue avec la langue
c'est une idée pas non plus bon la
première fois alors danse avec greg
oui à l'âge de 16 ans oui je dis oui
comme ça parce qu'il ya eu un effet avec
quelqu'un d'autre mais c'était un très
mauvais souvenir
ah bon c'est pas bien passé ma première
vraie foi voilà des premières fois avec
une fille c'était pour la thune faire
c'était pour l'anniversaire de greg je
comprends pas
pour résumer en plus souvent paré paré
un petit cadeau
il regarde exactement c'est une fille
dont j'avais envie et finalement c'était
pas prévu on était dans une soirée tout
ça et on est rentrés tous les trois
voilà qui sont la base du regret il ya
un bravo est bénie des dieux vous
rentrez jamais avec un copain
like pour avoir mes copains oui il
pourrait avoir envie de rentrer quatre
copains greg aussi frais que ce soit moi
qui en ai envie ah bon c'est vous qui
décidez oui mais je pense que c'est
normal dans un couple que ce soit la fin
la femme a plus besoin de choses pour le
sexe comme un homme c'est assez facile
elle est pas mal c'est bien enfin
souvent une fille a plus besoin d'eux
des choses pour donc première fois à
troyes vous venez de le dire première
fois 4 enfin tout dire c'était y'a pas
longtemps et a5 jamais ah bon vous êtes
tout à apprendre encore premières scènes
de ménage quand même j'espère c'est
assez a longtemps un beau coup de pub à
bon oui on discute beaucoup un nom aime
bien ouais vous aimez bien pour la
réconciliation bien sûr bien sûr les
premiers amours c'est qui votre premier
amour pareil non
gx et la collectionneuse
c'est un très beau but
et avec
et maintenant voici vous faire plaisir
vous qui avez fait beaucoup de handball
va arriver là c'est l'idole de tout le
monde c'est le plus grand de tous
percy jackson richardson
[Musique]
mais là on a beaucoup parlé de vous avec
costantini d'ailleurs oui dont vous êtes
capitaine de l'équipe de france de
handball qui est championne du monde et
ça ça vous savez comment on fait un
triomphe romain un triomphe romain
m
et voilà bravo ça n'en finit pas parce
que mercredi à marseille
vous avez battu la slovénie 31 à 27 à la
mi temps vous étiez à 15 14
ce n'était pas gagné du tout hein et
vous vous avez trois cent cinquante
sélections presque 350 sélections en
équipe de france
vous êtes le deschamps du handball ont
dit c'est ça ça vous va comme définition
hausse à l'honneur pour moi ouais
et si on veut vous voir on peut voir en
ce moment donc au tournoi de paris du 8
au 10 juin
ce document c'était là on est en plein
plein fin de saison et on a encore le
bercy pour nous c'est un moyen de se
retrouver par rapport à ce qu'on a pu
faire au mois de février ont trouvé n'a
publié que je pense qu'il n'y a pas
meilleur
mais enfin façon de récompenser le qu'on
pense qu'on a eu un mois de février
alors y ait quelqu'un ici qui nous a
beaucoup parlé de vous on va voir ce
qu'il a dit ou vous partez mais tout le
monde s'en va là non je sais pas moi je
fais un grand spécialiste du handball
mais ont-ils casa richardson martini
sent bon bon inutile c'est sur les
autres on a essayé un petit peu de fr
revenir sur leur décision parce qu'ils
sont quand même encore indispensable
parce que vous aidiez emballant de
richard stone c'est lui qui a permis de
gravir les échelons définitif
oui c'est un mec exceptionnel
exceptionnel voilà que santini qui parle
de vous alors
qu'est-ce qui fait maintenant comment
j'ai pas eu l'occasion de quoi passer
moins évolué en espagne lui laisse à
paris nettement plus nous et voilà vous
était vachement sympa avec lui parce
qu'aux championnats du monde
pendant la cérémonie de remise des
médailles vous êtes allé le chercher et
vous l'avez fait monter sur le podium
parce que c'était son dernier match en
tant que patron de l'équipe de france
depuis 92 on a enfin moi j'ai commencé à
vraiment remporter un titre c'est un 92
à barcelone
ouais et depuis on a à chaque fois il
avait toujours été à l'écart de tout
n'aurait pensé comme c'était son dernier
je suis dit autant il fait ce moment là
avec nous quand il eut la fin des
barjots costantini il a quand même fait
un peu le ménage dans l'équipe de france
vous il vous a gardé pour les costauds
donc l'équipe suivante alors vous
appelez jackson richardson donc
richardson c'est un nom c'est d'un colon
en fait c'est des colons anglo saxons
parce que souvent les esclaves avaient
le nom de leurs maîtres
d'une certaine façon c'était la réunion
donc vous êtes né et puis jackson c'est
parce que votre mère un jour a vu un
film et c'est je suis pas citer le héros
où l'acteur qui s'appelait jackson dans
tous les cas elle vous appelez jackson
était enceinte de vous moi je pense
qu'il a dû voir un fait mais jamais
vraiment posé la question et c'est aux
journalistes mais moi je me suis
vraiment renseigné leur visite né en
1969 au sud de l'île de la réunion à
saint pierre votre père et noir ils
s'appellent comme mon fils il s'appelle
gaston votre mère est blanche elle
s'appelle rose marie ce qu'il faut dire
oui c'est que votre père était un ancien
basketteur 1
et puis a été gardien dans le foot aussi
pompier votre père et son ambition
c'était vous en sortiez par le sport m
me line com
comme ils disent et savait pas c'est pas
très bien très bien écrire et si vous
savez pas lire alors pour lui ça et là
ça réussit à lui c'était dans le sport à
l'âge pour ça il ya toujours chez les
enfants juste dès notre plus jeune âge
j'ai fait trois sports le handball le
football et le basketball et tu as fait
des progrès mais il y j ai faut dire ces
injures etc toutes les équipes de
handball du monde voudrait avoir
jackson dans leur équipe et je tiens un
truc du tu sais pas tu as pris quelques
cours de golf un jour j'ai rencontré le
mec à qui tu faisais du practice
il a dit j'ai jamais vu ça de ma vie
wolf et ses dires au goût de 5,6
drive il tapé dans la balle quand c'est
évidemment une coordination incroyable
et tout donc voilà c'est ça c'est ça
c'est il faut dire merci à papa et à
maman
c'est ce qui fait votre force c'est
quand même mais justement c'est de la
fusion des trois sports dont le fait d
avoir pratiqué tous les trois d'un très
bon niveau
c'est bien ce qui fait votre
particularité ce que je me dis à chaque
fois enfin jean nous différents femmes
différencie des autres sportifs ou des
êtres des hôtes en valeur je dis
peut-être la force en moi c'est d'avoir
pratiqué ce sport que dans l'école
c'était pas terrible
ah non pas vraiment d'ailleurs c'est
pour ça maintenant j'ai dû tout ça à
tous les jeunes de qu'il faut surtout
pas négliger les études parce que
maintenant je gémis mère elle vous est
possible si vous aviez un entraînement
très tard le soir
et quand vous rentriez tard lendemain
matin de vous réveiller à 6 heures pour
faire toutefois non mais courageusement
elle a essayé en tous les cas un valls
est encore un sport on gagne beaucoup de
ce week-end même si tu es une star et
c'est d'ailleurs notre spécialité
si jackson était dans n'importe quel
autre spécialité ou le gulf un basket et
où ils seraient milliardaire savoir
quand même et puis alors vous arrivez au
bataillon de joinville à l'âge de 19 ans
pour faire votre service militaire très
dur d'arriver à ses fins moi j'étais
tellement que fier et content de dell
devenir métropole
c'est les trois premiers jours j'ai pas
j'ai pas réalisé comme c'est après que
j'ai là j'ai plus ma famille se lever à
l'heure le matin ce que j'aime bien chez
vous dites toujours la métropole alors
que les corses ils disent la france ça y
est c'est réglé vous vous dites toujours
la métropole
alors ce qui a été très sympa c'est que
les joueurs se sont cotisés pour vous
payez votre billet d'avion pour
retourner à la réunion pour noël et
alors deux ans après votre arrivée en 90
première sélection en équipe de france
avait effectivement assez vite
vous faites plusieurs clubs dont cannes
hier vitrolles vous amener aux
championnats d'europe en 93 et puis
l'allemagne parce que l'allemagne sous
la mère patrie du du handball
grosswallstadt vous jouez un crucial
stadt et vit maintenant pas plus loin
mais l'important c'est
génial lorsqu'elle drôle avec le
handball c'est qui ce sont les bleus
possible s'appelle les bleus dans leur
handball comme dans le football
quand été champion du monde avant les
valeurs
j'avais beaucoup de respect pour votre
père depuis le décès de votre père vous
avez créé un challenge qui s'appelle le
challenge gaston les chartes stone donc
et vous avez dit votre père signe toit
avant d'entrer sur chaque terrain vous
le fait toujours ça je vois toujours
c'est enfin mon père est très croyant
une vanne de l'éducation bahamas et
religieuse alors moi je dirais ses 9 ans
qui nous permet justement de faire
passer ma dernière difficulté ou de vous
sentez sa présence et sa force qui vous
êtes
enfin pour moi il est toujours comment
il est parti mais pour moi il est là
pour c'est un appel que je fais dans les
difficultés justement port promis d'y
amarrer ma famille pour pouvoir faire
passer bien alors comme tout va bien
pour vous référez quant à lui cauchemar
enlèvement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
interview cauchemar terrible vous allez
voir c'est terrible on va commencer avec
les accidents conjugaux ce qui serait le
pire pour vous ce serait de vous faire
surprendre par votre femme avec votre
maîtresse de surprendre votre femme avec
votre meilleur pote ou de surprendre
votre femme votre maîtresse ensemble je
pense que ça va être mon pote huawei
si vous surprenez vos satellites pour
moi je pense que je vivrai mal quoi
ouais je sais où aller je sais pas ben
va justement je préfère pas le savoir le
pire cadeau qu'on pourrait vous faire
des vacances avec jean marie bigard un
concert de chants classiques avec
lambert wilson une partie des quais avec
john's nl et business
le cancer allez
oui
les locaux ont certes connu la pire
situation ce serait d'avoir un pétard
mais pas de feu parce que la réunion
commence à peine à nyon lausanne annonce
zamar zamar mal zamal
oui je fais si j'y retourne peu que je
me remets dans la tête parce que sinon
si je demande illégale
on sait qu'ils m'avaient appris ça en
fait c'est thierry jean-pierre le juge
jean-pierre il est de la réunion de
zamal il m'avait expliqué ça alors donc
pires situations
un pétard mais pas de feu une carte
bleue mais pas de code ou une fille mais
pas de préservatif une fille c'était ça
serait terrible
je pense que ceci se passe en ce moment
non électret préservatif avec l'art
alors très très près à jouer très très
préservatif
le pire c'est un portable qui sonne tout
le temps ou un portable qui sonne jamais
jamais jamais et vous aimez on n'a pas
d'amis le pire c'est un portable
lambert wilson bonnes réponses le pire
pour vous ce serait d'être sdf ou
d'habiter dans une maison hantée par un
colon du xviiie siècle du sdf alors le
pire ce serait de connaître à l'avancé
le jour de votre mort ou d'ignorer que
vous êtes atteint d'un mal incurable
moi je préfère ignorer le 6 mai on est
venus tous atteints d'un mal incurable
va tous mourir oui le 200 oui c'est vrai
seul problème et le ce qui est génial
c'est qu'on sait pas quand ouais moi si
tu me dis c'est dans une demi heure j'ai
peut-être quitter le plateau pour aller
boire une bière
pas forcément rester ici le pire ça
serait plus vouloir toucher votre femme
ou plus pouvoir la toucher plus pouvoir
le pire ça va bientôt être fini le pire
c'est de grandir seul de vivre seul ou
de mourir seul jeu devrait mourir seul
tpir ça moi je prends soin moi je crois
j'ai vraiment plombé la différence là
l'an un jet plomber l'ambiance là il
faut un petit coup de l'art horaire il
faut un petit coup de la forêt des
marais côtiers
là
merci actuellement
alors quand vanessa paradis rue dans
cette émission il ya un disque d'elle
qu'on avait pas et qu'elle ne pas
risquer de nous donner
c'est un disque avec les forbans alors
depuis on la retrouve et on écoute
[Musique]
vanessa paradis les forbans disque
introuvable bien sûr on comprend
pourquoi
et maintenant voici ivan levaï
[Musique]
ivan levaï bonsoir don jackson
richardson évidemment on ne présente pas
puisque vous faites une revue de presse
tous les matins depuis sais pas combien
d'années donc vous avez dû entendre
parler de lui un jean marie bigard
oui voilà lambert wilson oui aussi et
clara morgane donc qui vient d'avoir le
dehors à cannes de la meilleure
starlette voilà qui était juste à côté
de sourds voulait bien que non mais
c'est gentil basse et la vie est belle
on sait vivre bien alors aujourd'hui
vous bien persévérer village alors bien
aujourd'hui vous aujourd'hui vous
persévérez dans votre sport favori
qu'est la revue de presse après europe 1
france inter a annoncé aujourd'hui vous
êtes sur france musique
à 8h30 tous les matins et vous êtes
président de la chaîne parlementaire de
l'assemblée nationale où vous animer une
émission qui s'appelle le droit de
questions c'est ça tous les vendredis
voilà et c'est rediffusée le samedi et
le lundi après midi à bayonne
alors vous avez été récompensés dont
clara morgane c'est un hot d'or vous ça
a été un item qui est un petit peu les 7
d'or du câble et du satellite donc votre
votre émission
oui oui voilà c'est la chaîne à un an et
l'émission a été remarquée repérer
bon on n'a pas encore tout à fait
l'audience de la vôtre mais mais ça
vient doucement dans votre ami elkabbach
qui vous a viré d'europe à l'huile à la
chaîne du sénat
oui partager des trucs quoi à huile et
au sénat ou les les sénateurs sont élus
vous savez pour très longtemps avant 9h
et très longtemps moi je suis à
l'assemblée nationale
ils sont 5 177 et c un peu plus court
ils ne sont élus pour cinq ans mais vous
n'êtes plus dynamiques lui fait plus
frais c'est comme en fait je vous
publiez un bouquin donc chez michel
lafon qui s'appelle la république des
mots
on sent que l'habitude de travailler que
ses mains il le fait très bien alors
coulé c'est vrai que voir richardson
faire ça ça fait plaisir
alors en 1986 dans le matin vous avez
déclaré j'ai un livre en chantier le
thème c'est un petit immigré ordinaire
qui décroche une partie du feu
prométhéen le pouvoir d'informer 186 et
ce bouquin ne vous sortez aujourd'hui
quinze ans après on se dit tous la même
chose je vais noter quelques petites
choses et puis je vais un jour je le
dirai ben voilà c'est vrai c'est la
barre est à l'horaire sont contents
parce qu'ils le disent tous ivan levaï
et ça marche bien mais c'est vrai alors
là vous raconter votre vie dans ce
bouquin on apprend vous êtes né à
budapest en 1937 de parents juifs d'un
père sans doute autrichien ne sont
voulait pas avouer pas connu d'une mère
hongroise modiste qui avait une boutique
rue p te fie à pest sur la rive gauche
du danube
hier vous y retournez vous raconter
qu'un jour quarante ans plus tard vous y
retourner avec des frigidaires écran
voilà j'ai mis du temps
ce qui est étonnant si vous mettez 40
ans donc pour retourner à à budapest et
qu' il vous faudra attendre les années
50 cette année en 37 pour savoir que
vous êtes juif c'est très c'est très
étrange parce que auparavant j'étais
persuadé est un bon petit français
cateau puis protestants est en fait vous
dites dans le bouquin vous rendez compte
vous appartenez à la république démolir
la république qui vous a instruit à la
halle et du sart noirs de la république
et puis au peuple du livre et ça vous
vous en rendez compte beaucoup beaucoup
plus tard alors justement pour échapper
à adolphe et à joseph quand vous avez
deux ans votre mère décide d'immigrer
alors départ il va loin en amérique
oui elle s'arrête appareil à cause de la
mode elle elle veut aller en amérique
parce qu'elle aille c'est le rêve
hollywoodien et elle se disait
je vais aller dans la cité du cinéma
avec mon fils et elle s'est arrêtée à
paris elle a bien fait tu m'as permis de
dire un jour à un politique français qui
est né à la trinité sur mer est content
d'être né à la trinité-sur-mer de lui
dire que lui il avait pas fait de gros
efforts tandis que moi je suis deux fois
français parce que ma mère a choisi la
france et moi j'ai choisi aussi d'être
naturalisé français donc le premier qui
me dit je ne suis pas français je lui
dis je le suis doublement raté quelque
chose de bien déjà contenu de l'époque à
laquelle vous étiez enfant elle vous a
fait baptiser vous dites c'était un
brevet pour la vie parce que ça vous a
permet quand même d'échapper pendant la
guerre a pas mal de risques catholique
ouais donc pour les juifs je suis juif
parce que l'association la naissance et
la mer pour les catholiques
je suis catholique parce que le plus
important c'est le baptême et on vous
n'allez pas me croire mais c'est vrai et
j'ai eu une éducation protestante à la
vie ses deux fils étaient les trois
sports et vous c'est des trois religions
alors votre maire al yom oui votre mère
eu un problème à la hanche elle était
hospitalisée à l'hôpital cochin vous a
été mis en nourrice en 40 basse et
l'exode vous êtes mis à l'assistance
publique votre mère reste un an dans cet
hôpital avant de mourir et d'être jeté à
la fosse commune
vous avez quelque chose d'un résilient
je pense vous connaissez cyril nuque oui
si on a le sentiment quand on lit ce
bouquin que toutes ces épreuves qui sont
terribles vite arriver à les dépasser à
les assimiler d'une certaine façon oui
parce que le bon hector-malot avait
écrit un livre qu'on lisait enfants qui
s'appelait sans famille le fait d'être
sans famille fait que on l'a bâti soi
même et on la trouve soi-même et la
famille s'élargit
d'une certaine façon j'ai des tas de
gens qui sont tellement contents d'avoir
un père une mère un grand-père des
ongles etc
mais en même temps c'est pesant pas
il ya les fêtes il faut aller voir moi
j'ai eu une à la fois une forme de
liberté dans la solitude envoyé quatre
sms non et puis vous épousez les
familles des femmes que vous rencontrez
ouais alors au retour de l'exode bas la
nourrice elle vient vous chercher à
l'assistance publique et elle devient
votre tutrice légale la boue qu'on dit
c'est à paris du côté de sharon
ménilmontant près du père lachaise la
place gambetta
alors votre enfance évidemment c'est
l'occupation c'est à dire c'est les
uniforme de la wehrmacht et voitures à
cheval
alors vous raconter un truc qui est
terrible c'est à dire ces enfants qu'on
vient chercher dans les salles de
classes qu'on emmène dans des abris
parce que des bombardements et qui
continue à la lueur de la bougie à
apprendre à lire ont quitté la salle de
wallace et on allait continuer
d'apprendre à lire un dans une cave et
après ça j'ai un site à lire jédir plus
confortablement
moi je trouve la vie en france des
années après au jour est incroyablement
confortable par rapport à ces années là
oui qu'est-ce que les années noires on
vous avez mangé le pain avant le
chocolat donc aujourd'hui ça vous semble
plus doux effectivement oui
alors aujourd'hui on a beaucoup de
chocolat way terrible époque donc vous
dites qu'on mettait des papier mouillé
dans le poêle godin pour que le papier
brûlent moins vite enfin c'est des trucs
qui sont absolument oui parce que
l'hiver 40 a été terrible 41
épouvantable
le 42e affreux et donc on peut les de
froid il ya pas de charbon alors voix
oui si vous en plus votre vie c'est pas
très tôt puisque vous faites la
vaisselle la lessive
vous avez conscience finalement d'offrir
une contrepartie pour l'hospitalité
qu'on vous offre
vous savez bien que vous n'êtes pas
l'enfant de sept rémy donc mais ça c'est
bien ça parce que ça vous sert toute
votre existence
mais aujourd'hui si plus personne ne
reprises les chaussettes mais je suis
reprise et les chaussettes alors vous
avez faim vous mangez même du savon de
marseille à un moment oui parce qu'on
ramassait
voilà des enfants sous les coulées le le
problème principal pendant l'occupation
en france toutes générations confondues
est la mienne
c'était bouffer c'était oms et on avait
faim et donc on va manger n'importe quoi
moi le buffet de la cuisine chez moi il
y avait de la saccharine du sucre de
raisin
et puis voilà puis un jour je suis mais
50 ans après le sucre les genres savons
de marché a changé c'est épouvante bien
sûr mais ne suit les genres si vous en
preniez ça se voyait quoi oui parce que
tout le monde serait un peu le sucre
quand même ri et alors vous mangez vous
manger des gâteaux et des bonbons
vitaminé à la récré de 10 heures et vous
imaginez que c'est le maréchal pétain
qui vous fait parvenir tout ça enfin les
élèves pas vous tous les élèves pensent
ça et un jour voulu écrivait une lettre
de remerciements au nom de toute la
classe alors ça c'était sur invitation
de mon institutrice paix à son âme
il a dû disparaître aujourd'hui qui nous
avait demandé de faire une lettre de
reconnaissance au maréchal est bon je
devais avoir une orthographe petit
immigré une orthographe convenable à
prix de france est donc on m'a demandé
au nom de l'ensemble de ma classe où il
y avait des petits juifs qui sont l
etoile d'écrire une lettre de
remerciement maréchal pétain dont mon
premier exercice journalistique si je
peux dire commandé un premier papier
commandés c'était une lettre au maréchal
que j'ai remercié persuadé que c'est à
lui que je devais les gâteaux de
vitamines et de la rega rentrer dans ce
petit juif qu'avait l'étoile vous parlez
d'un apple baume une histoire
extraordinaire moi je la fais absolument
réalité s'appelle appelbaum et il avait
fait une très belle rédaction pour
évoquer la rafle et les autobus citroën
sont là avec deux portes une à l'arrière
et une à l'avant on appelle et andy
applebaum et sa mère rend son enfant
dans les bras monte dans l'autobus et
pendant que les allemands et les
policiers français commandé qui les
accompagnait ouais continue de faire la
raf la mer monde traverse tout l'autobus
avec son enfant dans les bras sort par
la première porte et le gosse raconte
dans une rédaction saisissante qu'on
nous a lu en classe et dont je me
souviens encore ligne après ligne que
heureusement qu'il avait un nom qui
commence est bon parce que disait-il si
c'est un plaisir et que je serai pas là
pour raconter cette histoire
ouais ouais une autre histoire aussi qui
est très étonnant c'est que comme enfant
de prisonniers puisque le père de la
famille ou vivier était prisonnier vous
aideront à prendre des vacances avec
d'autres enfants de prisonniers ou
partent en vendée et là vous vous
rencontrez un type qui s'appelle en
allemand oui j'étais chez un épicier en
gros auprès de bressuire et un matin
arrive un camion de livraison et le
side-car des à des allemands qui
habitaient dans la même maison mais à
l'étagé au dessus nous on était à l'état
jean ba il y avait un prie-dieu portrait
du maréchal pétain et les braves gens
disaient vu comment faire entrer le
camion faut faire sortir le side-car d'
des officiers de la wehrmacht
alors comment faire et puis quelqu'un
eut l'idée de mettre le gosse sur le
side car moi et on m'a demandé
d'actionner la pompe actionnée à ponte
et hans qui était bien polis qui
disaient tous les soirs moutarde
après avoir ciré ses bottes des sens
mais éclats de rire me retire du
side-car me prend dans ses bras
mais voilà ce qui était les l'éducation
finalement l'éducation l'ambiance
générale donc il me prend dans ses
moyens et il me donne un bonbon il
fourre le bon moment dans la bouche et
la hurlements parce que on nous faisait
comprendre qu'il ne fallait rien
accepter des allemands le bonbon pouvait
être empoisonnés et le ranz m'a montré
des photos de lui
les photos de son gosse si c'est mieux
on a honte comment dire on n'imagine pas
ce qui a été cette france du du moisi
vous voyez du moisi y avait rien rien
rien que des petites histoires comme ça
mais ce créneau et ont croyait que les
allemands étaient là de toute éternité
allait rester là de toute éternité et
radio paris ment telle est la soeur et
radio paris était allemand radio paris
ment radio paris et allemands voilà ce
qu'on entendait sur les ont donc on
n'était pas bien quoi alors en parlant
de radio déjà l'âge de 8 ans vous rêvez
de médias intéressés par la presse je
vagabonde et sur des ondes imaginaire
est votre premier contact avec la radio
c'est un jeu sur radio luxembourg
c'est à dire vous raconter l'histoire de
monsieur champagne moi je me souviens de
sa et monsieur champagne il était
surveillant général au lycée condorcet
et au fond c'était pas si difficile que
ça parce que on allait préparer
l'émission été enregistré à bobino et
et rue de la gaîté et fallait d'abord
allé voir monsieur champagne au lycée
condorcet et alors là il disait moi la
première fois je vais le voir j'arrive
les mains dans les poches et me dit mais
alors t'as pas à porter tes bouquins du
nom mais comment tu veux que je
m'interroge
alors dans un deuxième rendez vous j'ai
avec mes bouquins et l'aurait le
problème c'était il tournait les pages
des livres de science d'histoire de
géographie
le seul problème c'était il est en train
de me faire mon petit questionnaire
alors deux attitudes possibles
je ne regarde pas enfin si je regarde
j'aurais moins à réviser bref on bat
jetait et si on veut acheter bien ce qui
a été mon cas
bon on gagnait donc vous avez connu ce
qui est extraordinaire dans l'histoire
premier salaire ça c'était c'est un peu
comme le film d'ettore scola qui
s'appelle nous nous sommes tant aimés et
sur un des trois personnages gagnent
gangan comme ça dans un jeu et la fin il
se plante sur vittorio de sica donc vous
c'est pareil si vous gagnez vous gagnez
et un jour j'ai le sentiment qu'on vous
fait perdre pour faire gagner un fils de
déporté ouais j'ai eu le deuxième prix
cela dit mon mari on m'a posé une
question qui était je voulais pas y
répondre c'est à dire en gros c'était
une question impossible
l'animateur s'appelait il s'appelait
jean jacques vita avec très déçu par
jean-jacques vital parce que vous
l'entendiez à la radio on pensait que
c'était un type très jeune et quand vous
le découvrez vous apercevez qu'il un
show il est chauve bedonnant et vous
avez très 18 juin jean jacques dans la
famille durable en toile
donc moi je vois jean jacques vital qui
était toute la france disait c'est un
jeune et je découvrais et puis bon je
gagne le deuxième prix et c'était pas si
mal parce que c'était 50 mille francs de
l'époque
mais ce n'était pas 100 mille francs
après vous mariez vous vous retrouvez à
ces terribles vous retrouvez gong tai
annoncé après les horreurs de la guerre
c'est terrible c'est que vivant se
retrouvent comptables aux fermetures
éclair dans la boîte qui des fermetures
éclair donc là c'est toute la journée
des gens là-bas dans des petites cases
comme ça il rangeait toutes les tailles
de fermeture éclair que les mercière de
province l'arc au board est ce une
histoire absolument vous êtes prof après
vous devenez profs et un jour vous lisez
dans le monde une annonce europe numéro
un à l'époque cherche un jeune rédacteur
publicitaire et là aussi c'est
incroyable vous faites une espèce de
concours pour rentrer à rome numéro un
et le votre concierge chez vous oublie
de vous donner la lettre disant que
j'étais engagé quoi donc quand il voit
là et là c c'est pour ça fausse jamais
s'affoler quand tu y arrives des
tragédies ce jour là je me suis mis
c'est terrible le rêve de ma vie à
travailler à la radio et ou à quelle
radio la radio de la guilde europe 1
bon c'était la seule et et le jour où on
dit qu'on vous engage parce que
rédacteur publicitaire ça me permettra
d'être journaliste le concierge garde le
gars de la dette
quand vous pointez diby lui-même en
pauvre vieux non on a pris deux secondes
alors j'y suis foutu c'est foutu parce
que vous rentrez à l'express la grande
époque de l'express justement françoise
giroud et d'autre et après qu'un sac
bien sûr et grands grâce à ça vous
rentrez europe numéro un où vous ferez
rerentrer d'ailleurs michèle cotta parce
que l'époque est pas beaucoup de femmes
qui pouvaient travailler à la radio 1
votre patronne ma patronne
thierry franches montagnes vient
l'interroger pendant michel là non pas
du tout ce soir ce soir c'est très sage
alors c'était europe de l'époque de
siéger algorithmique louis merlin voilà
pile à vous devenez une star bon après
tout le monde connaît l'histoire je lui
racontais le début parce qu'après tout
le monde connaît expliquez vous sur
europe 1 c'est une émission mais qui
existe toujours aujourd'hui elle est
présentée par jean-pierre elkabbach
mais elle existe toujours et puis non
mais c'est vrai c'est une émission
extraordinaire parce que ce qu'elle est
très fort dans l'émission c'est que vous
déranger les gens posent est élevé qu'en
même temps six minutes c'était la
première irrévérence du truc ça évite de
dire bonjour monsieur vs comme vous êtes
vous êtes formidables vous allez prendre
des mesures ou comme c'est bien et c'est
en six minutes avec une personnalité
politique on peut pas être très poliment
mais c'est bien ce que les gens ont cru
que j'étais agressif les champs alors
que vous étiez blessé s'était pressée
voilà et puis bon alors en 82 le liban
est à feu et à sang vous recevez
l'ambassadeur du liban à paris qui
comparent béguines le patron d'israël à
hitler dans une réaction très violente
évidemment vous est écartelé entre votre
sympathie naturelle pour israël votre
compréhension du problème palestinien et
votre job de journaliste
et là on vous reproche vos prises de
position sur le mans et lorient qui sont
très pro israélienne oui parce que j'ai
l'impression que l' équilibre n'est pas
dans le sens que l'on croit aujourd'hui
encore le gens sont tous persuadés que
c'est israël qui doit donner qui doit
donner recoupées avec ses vêtements
il ya une chose qui m'est qui m'est
insupportable s'est parlé d' équilibre
quand on accepte une attitude de
déséquilibre je voudrais dire que une
seule chose une seule chose gaza
aujourd'hui par exemple on vous parle de
gaza la zone ce qui se passe à gaza est
épouvantable moi je voudrais pas vivre à
gaza
mais une chose qu'on ne sait pas où on
dit passé on a proposé aux égyptiens
d'avoir la tutelle de gaza après tout ce
sont leurs frères en religion
l'egypte n'a jamais voulu donc
aujourd'hui on fait de gaza un problème
israélien mais
pardon de dire ça c'est un problème ah
ben oui oui vous voyez ça on ne le dit
jamais elle c'est bien mais vous citez
dans votre bouquin la fameuse lettre de
jules ferry qui s'appelle la lettre aux
instituteurs ou jules ferry dit aux
instituteurs formidable cette époque
vous ne pouvez pas prendre parti et moi
dieu sait si j'ai eu des instituteurs
qui était de parti-pris vous aussi vous
avez un cow-boy moi aussi un brin on a
tous eu des instituteurs qui signent
nous bourrer le mou ex biologie
politique et jules ferry avait écrit que
l'instituteur ne pouvait pas prendre
parti est ce que cette idée de la lettre
aux instituteurs devrait pas s'appliquer
aux journalistes d'une certaine façon
est ce que vous aurez par votre
attachement naturel à israël vous prenez
parti souvent en faveur des israéliens
au moyen-orient est-ce que c'est pas un
problème ça alors c'était un problème
la lettre de jules ferry vous avez
raison elle est splendide parce que
c'est parler aux enfants en pensant que
ce que vous dites vous seriez capable de
le dire de la même manière si leurs
parents étaient présents dans la salle
de classe d'actes ça c'est une attitude
formidable
moi aujourd'hui je serai là 2001
je trouve que le journalisme pas le juge
pas les gens par les journalistes jeudi
le système journalistique est devenu
d'une tiède est d'une fadeur
extraordinaire c'est à dire tout se vaut
tout le monde est gentil tout le monde
est beau alors ça bouge pour un petit
peu de jeu ce pas un petit peu de chirac
vous mettez un peu de bayrou par dessus
oui du bayrou par dessus ça m'est
insupportable jeu bref je regrette je
regrette l'époque pas si ancienne qui à
20 ans 30 ans ou au moins c'était un peu
car et c'est là on disait par vous
monsieur passé en argumentaire
aujourd'hui on argumente e plus et c'est
vrai dans le consensus non au consensus
mou voilà non au conformisme vous
approchez aussi votre yves montand de la
tri ah bah oui mais là je suis un
inconditionnel de mon temps à l'aller on
vous approchez votre mitterrandolâtre il
à l'époque
l'époque est aux crachats curieusement
et disons que j'aime pas les modes les
mêmes qui étaient couchés devant
mitterrand aujourd'hui soit font du fric
avec eux et je ne nomme personne soit
disons qu'il est de bon ton de duroux et
on va regarder comment alors l'adultère
les enfants tous et c est moi j'ai envie
de dire je ne regrette je vais vous dire
ce que je ne regrette pas dans 80 c'est
grâce à la gauche et aux français et 1
rang il y a eu alternance depuis
mitterrand vous avez remarqué on change
et moi j'adore ça
mais le problème en fait si vous étiez
pote avec mitterrand vous êtes là en 80
quand on lui apprend qu'il est président
de la république le 10 mai la
journaliste mollo du point qui lui dit
vous êtes président des hauts revenus il
réagit pas failli resterez comme ça il
vaut mieux ça que le contraire oui non
il a été il s'est efforcé à
l'impassibilité il a eu un petit
battement de cils quand même un
battement de cils attendait
quand vous apprenez que vous êtes bien
sûr là ça fait là c'est ce que je veux
dire mais bon vous êtes proche de lui
vous êtes là quand il est là apprend
qu'il est président ensuite vous avez
souvent à la che quand même avec anne
sinclair
witt deux votes soit deux fois on n'a
pas arrêté 80 étaient 82 mais c'était
bien ouais c'était bien moi
si jacques chirac m'a vite à brégançon
je suis poli et civilisée gérer avec
plaisir je me posais une question aux
hyènes aléas à colombey-les-deux-églises
vous éteignez la lumière chez vous et
ici aussi
est ce que vous croyez pas ivan levaï
quand même que la promiscuité des
grandes c'est à dire la fréquentation
que vous aviez de mitterrand vous a
amené certaines fois avoir un jugement
mois objectif que celui qu'on était en
droit d'attendre de quelqu'un d'aussi
écouté que vous non moi j'ai pas peur de
la connivence des journalistes et des
hommes politiques
il ya une chose que je redoute c'est la
malhonnêteté
or il ya des hommes politiques qui sont
malhonnêtes avec des journalistes des
journalistes qui sont malhonnêtes avec
des hommes politiques
voilà c'est tout chacun chez soi lui il
est élu vous vous ne l'êtes pas et on ne
se doit rien moi je ne dois rien je vais
inviter à la che comme c'est tout ça
vous ne venez pas être plus sympas avec
mitterrand que si vous n'aviez pas été
invité non ça permet de voir ce qu'il y
a ceux qui demeurent d'humanité vrai
chez les hommes que vous rencontrez et
je fume
alors parallèlement à votre histoire
d'amour avec europe 1 vous avez une love
story avec anne sinclair donc ayant le
chapitre dans votre bouquin s'appelle
trop belle pour moi oui mais je crois
que le titre du chapitre du tout c'est
vrai il suffit de les regarder de me
regarder trop belle pour moi quelqu'un
quand vous rentriez le soir elle vous
disais tu as vu sept sur cette question
là pensez vous disais je n'ai vu que tes
yeux
non c'est pas tout à fait ça je lui
disais que à la télévision on regarde
ouais donc on perd un peu du sens moi je
pars dont un de vous dire ça mais on est
bien ici mais dans l'ordre c'est un la
presse écrite
1 la presse écrite un la presse écrite
tout de suite après la radio est en fait
la télévision oui le livre pourquoi ai
je le disais à ain si c'est parce que le
temps qu'on perd à te regarde et on
n'écoute pas ce que tu dis est vrai et
je dis je t'écoute pas moi et d'ailleurs
ceci étant le nombre de français qui oui
c'est vrai avec la même attitude avec
ses pulls mohair dany blatt seulement
huit mois c'est vous que les conseils
sur la télé en tous les cas elle voulait
faire de la radio m non elles et elles
sont son rêve c'était de travailler à
europe 1 elle était europe 1 et puis la
garder à lui a proposé en tout bien tout
honneur la botte c'est à dire d'être sa
collaboratrice directe elle n'a pas
voulu parce qu'elle voulait être
journaliste et elle m'a dit qu'est ce
qui m'arrive et je lui dit tu vas être
viré d'européens patron ne supporte pas
longtemps et a dit mais ça va être
terrible ginon toi tu es fait pour la
télévision et c'est vrai et elle ne
voulait pas et non la télévision tu
rends compte je serai paralysé et
toucher non ton médias c'est la
télévision et est la preuve a été faite
qu'en mai 14 ans à tf1 et quatre ans
aussi en plus là et vient comment on dit
d'être remercié 1 c'est pas mal hein
ouais c'est pas malin pour tf1 cela fait
pas mal au fait comment ça vous fait de
la peine pour eux oui parce que c'était
elle était du crédit de la légitimité et
c'est de l'intelligence de tf1 qui sera
sans béton l'intelligence qui s'en va
d'un média il en reste un peu et vous
derrière ce qui est très bizarre dans
cette affaire c'est que vous le le début
de la fin de votre histoire d'amour avec
anne sinclair c'est quand vous été viré
d'europe 1 par elkabbach donc vous aviez
fait revenir faut savoir quand même
c'est qui vend le vague a fait revenir
elkabbach sur europe 1 et tout le monde
le dit fais gaffe tu faire entrer le
loup dans la bergerie fais gaffe mais
non mais non ils vous attirer vous aviez
faire entrer le loup dans la bergerie
alors vous partez mais c'est vrai j'ai
fait une erreur alors dans l'audiovisuel
tissot présente de gens qui en vire
d'autres vous savez ça vous et qui font
des erreurs gravissime et il est paye
après il les paye away temps des moules
et je vous donne les noms les derniers 1
y'en a qu'on vire et bouvard oui bon et
c'est que c'est vrai alors vous non
voilà ce qu'il faut dire c'est que vous
vous partez au provençal donc que sa
partenaire lagardère s'est occupé du
provençal
elle c'est la grande époque de 7 sur 7
et voilà quoi ouvrez là quoi vous fait à
paris le dimanche pour la voir elle
prépare son émission qui est en direct
donc le dimanche après midi et le boss
si vous voulez un peu de temps pour moi
et pour la famille je redescends marcela
voilà c'était
et voilà ce qui est dans ce genre de
situation ce qui devait arriver arrive
ouais voilà oui ouais mais vous voyez
toujours et toujours copain avec quelle
façon vous êtes des enfants ensemble
avec calme
oui oui bien sûr bien sûr strauss kahn
cette copa vécu oui pourquoi
non j'ai pas je vous demande mais
attendez non mais non vous posez la
question je vous réponds bah oui vous
savez il ya des familles on se retrouve
parce que je me suis monsieur c'était
c'est terrible parce qu'on est amené à
parler de soi alors que joueurs et les
fait bien ça et le fait très bien
mais bon je vais jusqu'au cou lorsque je
me suis remarié il ya cinq ans avec une
bordelaise à doral catherine qui est
venu à mon mariage
mes enfants ma femme bien sûr mon
ex-femme et dominique strauss kahn les
frais
[Musique]
alors ivan levaï vous avez eu des uhsa
eu débat on va faire une interview à
peine deux ans la bouche maintenant le
jingle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce que vous préférez en vous la parole
ce que vous détestez en vous le physique
si vous préférez dans la presse plantu
ce que vous détestez dans la presse les
éditoriaux qui commence par il faut
raison garder ce que vous préférez dans
la radio le direct ouais et le fait que
c'est le téléphone
l'autre est à l'autre bout ouais donc je
te parles tu me réponds pas le tu sens
que je suis là je sens que tu es là
aussi si vous détestez dans la radio ce
qui parle pour ne rien dire
le plus grand moment de votre vie un
jour à la fenêtre
j'habitais rue de l'arbre sec au coin de
la rue de rivoli passe une limousine et
dans la limousine il ya deux types qui
salue la foule
charles de gaulle et john fitzgerald
kennedy
ouais et je suis là ouais et puis on a
un autre jérusalem
sa date vient d'arriver et béguines est
à côté et ça date se demande s'il doit
mettre la kippa des juifs
et puis bégué il lui fait signe que non
et voilà et j'assiste à j'insiste à la
libération mais j'assiste à ce que je
croyais la paix c'est un deuxième grand
moment inouï inouïe et je rencontre qui
pierre mendès-france qui me dit c'est
formidable c'est formidable j'ai pas vu
ça depuis la fin de la guerre ouais ça
c'est un un moment inouï le pire moment
de votre vie c'est c'est l'absence de
s'ignorer ouais city et signoret
delattre si oui votre plus belle
histoire d'amour wetton merde alors
je passais crime c'est la première la
plus belle non il y en a une à qui j'ai
dit
gg j'ai cinq minutes pour faire ce que
j'ai envie de faire c'est à dire vous
embrasse et voilà et elle m'a embrassée
et voilà et on s'est posés si vous savez
qui c'est vous nous appelez le numéro
s'inscrit en bas de l'écran votre plus
moche histoire d'amour or si la plus
belle et c'est la plus moche parce que c
est laisser la plus brève et c'est la
plus courte
voilà c'est au chili c'est seth killian
aux proches d' alien des mondes jeu
c'est vrai que vous retrouvez à
valparaiso complètement par hasard les
acteurs français mais vous avez tout lu
tout ça vous étonne si vous êtes de plus
sexy en vous je comprends je poche chez
packard annoncé comme non pas comme tous
les hommes jeu comme tous les hommes
c'est une banalité de dire ça mais je
vais quand même il paraît que les femmes
sont sont séduites quand on les fait
rire ouais donc je fais rire les femmes
d'accord peut-être que la manière de
dire hey sexy en sais rien ça suffit pas
on rate ce que vous avez de moins sexy
en vous mais colère ce que vous préférez
dans le sexe avant si vous détestez le
lendemain matin
la faune
et maintenant je dis au revoir à lambert
wilson lambert allez vous coucher
oui allez vous coucher le petit norbert
le pétillant et salé
le
deux ans
tiaret
et maintenant
[Applaudissements]
ah ouais ouais si sharleen spiteri
calme
[Applaudissements]
jalouse
vous parlez vous parlez français vous
préférez qu'on parle anglais
alors pour parler anglais on a quelqu'un
[Applaudissements]
belinda wii commence à très bien et vous
êtes à l'antenne bévinda décrivez vous
physiquement 1 mais vous me posez sur la
même question il est l'un des centres
maintenant de la tête j'ai un coup pas
mal oui bah vous descendez un peu alors
non je crois que ce sera pour la
prochaine fois vous regardiez promis la
poitrine ce soir ah non non non la
poitrine on n'en parle pas pourquoi mais
je vous ai déjà dit que vous êtes si mon
fantasme sexuel dont que vous dit
qu'ouvrir un temps la chienlit non on se
connaît depuis longtemps parce qu'en
fait la première télé du groupe texas en
france c'était dans une émission qui
s'appelait lunettes noires pour nuits
blanches
[Musique]
je te masser
king est
m
paris
[Musique]
voir
voilà ça fait une spécialité
amoura je me teins alors à l'époque j'ai
complètement flashé sur vous qui me
vient jeter un regard mais terrible
scène avec glace et j'ai dit j'ai aucune
chance en fait vous parlait bien
français et seulement quand vous êtes
bourrés à saissac en france est
difficile quand elle est saoul elle
parle bien parce qu'elle s'en fout des
fautes de français d'al femmes général
polonais d'où l'expression saoul comme
un polonais alors il faut dire que vous
avez une grand mère française et votre
père avec une 36 ans à bordeaux et
beaucoup de familles à bordeaux et puis
quand vous avez eu il ya quelques années
des problèmes de carrière vous êtes venu
vous réfugier à paris auprès d'une
styliste qui s'appelle corinne cobson
donc ça explique que peut-être tout à
l'heure on nous dirait quelques mots en
français
alors osez au début vous étiez pas aux
débuts du groupe texas métier pas
tellement en avant et mélanger non
maintenant vous êtes devenu un peu le
porte parole du groupe
parce que vous dites les autres membres
du groupe sont trop timides pour
contredire les journalistes mentalement
je suis effectivement parole en tant que
ça s'est mis effectivement je suis un
peu âgées maintenant ça fait 15 ans
cgt après patrick ans et j'étais un
petit peu la femme dans le monde la
musique je voulais qu'on me voit comme
un coût beaucoup ce groupe et une fois
qu'on a établi ce ceux ci et ça a été
beaucoup plus facile pour les gens de
m'accepter vous pensez vous ferez une
carrière solo un jour est en jeu ça ne
m'intéresse pas vraiment jamais je ne
sais pas toi je suis pas en fermant
quelqu'un qui chipera performance si la
musique de linda quand elle est née
versé never c'est le type de james bond
et toi tu nous fais la fontaine je ne
boirai pas de ton dos à je te le dis
belinda c'est un peu voilà merci thierry
tendre et j'apprends mon métier me
goubin je sais moi aussi bien alors
aujourd'hui bien oui c'est tout
le d
ses plus grands tubes de texas
[Musique]
m
oui
je suis là aussi
à
bien alors non ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que le dernier lundi
je l'adoré je les aime beaucoup
et alors le clip de texas sur le dernier
morceau qu'on a entendu de texas
s'appelle inard smile il est génial
puisque sharleen spiteri et en elvis
presley
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis
[Musique]
source
alors 9 heures de maquillage 9 heures de
maquillage pour devenir vice presse les
6,6 aux années c'est énorme c'est pour
ça que c'est elle la porte parole du
groupe à ce qu'elle est capable de
contredire les journalistes arrêtés à
glasgow
votre père était capitaine dans la
marine marchande votre mère est
infirmière
non ma mère n'a jamais été à bord tu
oses moins quelqu'un qui travaillait
dans la décoration des vitrines et le
travailler dans la mode
ah bon mais je vais refaire à nos
problèmes donc vous allez voir vous êtes
né à glasgow votre père était capitaine
de la marine marchande votre mère
travaille dans la mode se couper des
vitrines
la musicienne donc beaucoup
d'instruments la maison beaucoup de 10
aux parents vous ont fait cadeau de leur
collection de disques et après le lycée
vous êtes coiffeuse je suis devenue
coiffeuse au début des années 80 quand
j'ai quitté l'école et m'ont dit est-ce
que ça t'intéresserait des coiffeuses
pour garder un prêt d'argent pour que je
puisse payer mon loyer votre vocation de
chanteuse c'est quand vous voyez joe
strummer de clash la télévision
il faisait ce que je voulais faire il
avait une attitude dans la vie qui m'a
pas elle avait cette passion l'art cet
amour et c'est ce que je vais faire et
je n'ai jamais rêvé d'être un musicien
quand j'étais enfant je pensais que je
serais une artiste et je suis tombé dans
la musique qui je veux dire à 17 ans
ouais quand vous avez rencontré johnny
mcelhone c'est ça c'est ça
vous avez fait texas ensemble alors au
début vous appelez le groupe texas en
hommage au film de wim wenders parisse
texas et quand vous allez aux états unis
et vous voyez le texas ça a été vraiment
une déception quand on était rio texas
la première chose que j'ai vue c'est à
dire si j'étais vraiment choqué parce
que c'était rien de ce que nous imaginer
mais en fait on sort du simply paris
vous faites un gros succès et votre
premier succès c'est ça
ça marche bien et après les deux albums
suivants sont quand même des bides débit
quand même 2 millions tradition et deux
albums par la suite vendus en france et
c'est ce qui nous a permis de garder la
carrière cette carrière et c'est grâce à
l'achat des français donc d'un seul vous
étiez un peu les rois du monde et puis
d'un seul coup c'est devenu un peu un
peu plus loser d'une certaine façon il
ya eu des rumeurs de séparation à ce
moment-là du groupe texas toujours des
rumeurs vont se séparer
on fait rien quand c'est dur d'écrire
des chansons
je vivais toujours et je voulais essayer
de marsan création et j'avais déjà eu
des gens qui travaillent avec moi et
essayer d'identifier le faire je devais
tard il s'était pas vraiment mon idée
c'est pas mon intérêt
je ne voulais pas s'y être à sybille est
brisé et je suis parti tout simplement
alors quand vous revenez au sommet avec
white en blonde première d'exemplaires
et un nouveau look un peu un peu plus
androgyne ciel en fête vous ce qui fait
votre force qui vous plaisait aussi bien
aux hommes qu'aux femmes
taddei on va voir tout de suite par a
évidemment évidemment évidemment non
mais c'est vrai déjà quand vous étiez
petit vous refusiez de jouer à la fille
de minauder dur belinda minauder le fait
d'être femme c'est pas quelque chose qui
m'oblige être très féminine est une ode
hier et j'ai beaucoup aimé voir les
femmes qui savent ce qu'elles veulent
dans la vie et c'est vraiment le genre
de personne qui m'attire c'est un peu
ambigu quand même ça vous êtes devenu
une idole pour les lesbiennes par
exemple en fait les gens disent mais
d'être appréciée par les autres femmes
qu'elle soit lesbienne pas véritablement
un gros compliment qu'on me fait ça ne
me dérange absolument pas c'était papou
j'ai un ami vous savez ah bon vous ne
dérangez pas investi et grands dans la
musique semble être effective manquer
dans ce jeu vous deux
c'est un détail
allez
le gamer semailles
maintenant je vais dire au revoir à
notre ami jackson richardson va parce
que comme il joue bas est obligé d'aller
se reposer sa gare son salut jackson
merci
ward
le remaniement
allez demain à bercy
[Applaudissements]
et maintenant mesdames messieurs j
attends je vous que tel film soit
terriblement jalouse témoin
mais ce qu'il fallait simplement c'est
qu'elle se sente pas trop écrasé
j'ai laissé espérer s'en trouve facilité
ma victoire qu'elle aussi peut-être les
otages mais c'est plus joli
[Musique]
vous connaissez tous le monde connaît
tout le monde
biger sharleen spiteri lardons de
laisser bien sûr ivan levaï
oui clara morgane mais mardi sont
peut-être s'est pas joué encore monsieur
greg un bon mois ça va ça va bien ça va
bien
bon alors depuis du feu les jeudis plus
bien je dis bon bon alors depuis dix ans
m
vous avez deux créations la si jolie vie
de sylvie est une pièce assez
autobiographique
et puis la cigale et la jolie composé de
sketches inédits mais évidemment tout le
monde vous réclamez c'est normal tout le
monde vous réclamez ça j attends jour
quelqu'un m'a terriblement cher
voilà sûrement de réclamer sa commande
le réclamait la lettre à johnny madame
toucha le talion richelieu l'interview
la mousse au chocolat à vos grands
classiques d'une certaine façon le
mannequin vedette experts et là vous
avez cédé au harcèlement
il faut mieux céder au harcèlement nous
tous vos fans et vous sortez donc à la
fois il ya un spectacle et un cd on sait
comment c'est un oui vous a dit un oui
ils vous ont expliqué c'est ça c'est sûr
très bien alors il ya un spectacle au
casino de paris etc je suis votre idole
est un disque qui s'appelle pareil voilà
alors on va voir à quoi ça ressemble non
d'abord je vais dire que c'est jusqu'au
16 juin
magnéto mais lui qu'elle le pet espèce
d'aspect rj couvert de sueur on
ce qui était à côté de moi à table ils
purent quand ils ont passé à cette
mousse
il est effrayant leur fils on dirait un
cochon un bep de show à chécy colère il
m'a dit la grosse touche à la fin n'est
pas notre conduite
on l'appelle à truyes au volant
ça ma femme est en confiance j'étais
passé à cher au courage et dont il était
un mois que je trouve qu'à l'étranger
une française n'a pas le droit ne peut
pas ça mais d'autres médias en open moi
je ne vois pas voilà sylvie joly donc au
casino
rigole jusqu'en juin 2016 en belle sur
l'île votre âge non je m'en fous j'ai 17
ans vous l'avez dit ça mérite de la
grave dit non et vous né d'une famille
catteau bourges bah oui vous vous
montrez des cvg mon père officier de
marine
oui c'est charlie et emma marine
marchande son père pendant ce soir
famille assez traditionnel où il n'est
pas bien vu d'autres artistes cercle pas
être pas du tout un supporter d'être
artiste professionnel mouais artistes
comme ça ça va
voilà vous avez c'est vrai quand elle
quand on avait un talent caché dans la
famille de sylvie joly fallait exercer
en secret
voilà un amateur en la matière est une
autre arrière grand oncle eu par exemple
qu'à la comédie française
la personne a tardé c'est à dire que ça
c'était le rêve d'un grand mère qui
était à la comédie française avec un
pseudonyme et ils étaient cinq enfants
quand on a mon arrière-grand-mère
combien vous aviez
et d'enfants alizés 4 sur les photos de
famille y avait une tache d'encre à la
place de cet homme là a changé quand
même regarder et clara morgane elle fait
du dixel descend voir ses parents avec
son jury
bon voilà papa maman on a décidé avec
grec de faire du x mais mes enfants
c'est par un problème ça a changé quand
même parce qu'à l'époque de sidi la
comédie française c'était mal vu des
comptes s'il avait fait du x votre goût
vous dites alors un truc un peu quand
même un peu gonflé quand même vous dites
il est plus difficile de s'imposer quand
on vient d'un milieu aisé
oui je crois que c'est petit c'est moi
je suis d'accord avec toi c'est simple
si vous lui il vient a mis les aristos
et je n'arrive pas à pleurer sur
l'enfant d'une famille aisée même quand
il est contrarié c'est précisément ça
qui est dur c'est qu'on pleure pas sur
ces précisions sec et tourna locales à
l'école le gosse de riche
moi j'aurais jamais voulu être un gosse
de riche à ce que le gosse de riche à
lui dit attends tu vas quand même pas de
plaindre des parents ils ont besoin de
gagnants et tout est souvent il a tout
sauf l'amour
il a beau sac et l'impôt sac en cuir il
a des beaux stylos mais il a pas d'amour
et celui là il beaucoup plus malheureux
que que des enfants de port vendres qui
n'a pas d'amour évidemment et qui est
malade
elle
alors vocation comique assez précoce on
vous dit je suis né clown et comme vous
êtes croyante
vous avez considéré très tôt votre
vocation c'était un deux voire d'une
certaine façon d'exploiter votre talent
comique c'est une espèce de volonté
mystique pour faire du bien aux gens oui
c'est vrai à un moment donné je me suis
dit bah oui c'est vrai que si on se
donne et on a l'impression qu'on est
doute pour quelque chose et que ça fait
10 pas d'image au genre pays bien oui
exactement
ils auraient tort enfants vous ont été
renvoyés de cette institution religieuse
et vous êtes retrouvés dans la classe de
bernadette chirac a été comment les
pièces jaunes non non elle était
élèves bons élèves ouais ce qui était
facile
ils sont par rapport à l'or après le bac
vos parents vous interdise de devenir
actrice et votre père vous dit puisque
tu veux tu exprimes et a4 avocate et
dans la boue choisissez celui qui habite
le plus près de chez vous c'est maîtrise
horny vous saviez quand même que ça
avait été l'avocat de pétain et tout ça
oui oui oui vous allez après on peut
être l'avocat de pétards marquer mais
tout le monde a droit à un avocat mais
il avait quand même des idées à ses
actionnaires maîtrise au reniement
c'est pas moi je veux à tout le monde un
désigner contradictoires moi j'ai connu
une journée il était tombé amoureux de
son client
ouais ce qui arrive là est vraiment y
avait des milliers assassiné il était
fasciné par l'homme qui l'avait qu'il
avait défendue alors réalisé qu'au delà
des effets de manche
il est comme les tonne de paperasse dans
ce boulot d'avocat et puis la
responsabilité puisque vous dites si je
fais paris un soir c'est pas grave mais
si le mec qui prend dix ans parce que
j'ai mal plaissan merde on dira que ça
puisqu'elle va la peine de mort zilla
j'ai oublié un truc vous avez quand même
c'est un peu beaucoup de responsabilités
pour moi je dit marié depuis sept ans
pour vous annoncer à votre mari
finalement voulais être comédienne quoi
si vous aviez ça vraiment chevillée au
corps quoi et votre mari dit oui
je savais que tu étais arty vous êtes
vraiment oui c'est vrai c'est une chance
j'ai du bol quoi alors je vais vous dire
que j'ai dis bah bah vous avez du
bassiste et 40 ans qui est avec vous
même un peu puisque à lavage il vient
bien vient au spectacle ils viennent
dans vos spectacles
il rit alors vous voyez votre navire
s'était pas dire qu'il est le seul à ce
que je veux dire ça mais ça nous
encourage c'est normal passionné mais
j'ai souvent j'ai chaque fois que j'ai
vu ci lui j'étais à côté de son mari il
respire avec celui qu'il avait commencé
à y aurait de toute façon si les est pas
là moi j'aurai je n'aurais pas fait ça
je ne serais pas arrivée un ouais c'est
trop dur cette histoire c'est dur la
culture vous êtes une fille courageuse
parce que quand vous décidez de devenir
comédienne vous prenez des causes au
cours simon faisait l'école de tania
bacha bas j'avais l'école de tania belle
la chaux va y arriver là j'ai fait
quelque chose comme 6 très bref non mais
si vous prenez des cours avec avec le
cours simon par exemple d'aller au petit
conservatoire de huy magna britannia
balagne à tenir c'est à dire le cheval à
jouer du classique au départ joyau tesco
ne s'est pas préparé des sahraouis ce
que je pouvais pas passer largement
dépassé large et que là vraiment y aller
ou poursuivre où j'avais trente 30
verges dont pensons que je fasse allait
passer célimène et tout ça ça marche pas
je fais rien [ __ ] c'est au début des
années 70 ce que vous décidez de
carrière commis alors là oui c'est dit
allons-y essayons de gala que je fais
pas ça me fait vraiment c'est magnifique
avec des rideaux bleus
oui je vois comme une sorte de paradis
est agréable c'est le paradis on l'a
fait à leval juste avant était ravie
aussi oui le secret quand même s'est
jamais cherché à être drôle parce que là
c'est fichu c'est oui c'est non c'est
vrai je pense pas que c'est ce que chez
nous et tu feras c'était pense la même
chose que si on est ici on est surpris
en flagrant délit de de vouloir être
drôle c'est moi bien que d'être
directement drôle bien aller visionner
au caire
il ya le discret spectacle au casino
puisqu'on sait jamais
vient alors la le pire est à venir je
vous le dis tout de suite
l'interview expliqué à ma petite fille
on ne bouge pas pendant les ting
[Musique]
ça veut dire quoi annie aime les
sucettes à l'anis
ça veut rien dire michel ahnee
grand-mère de son à la télé il a dit
nash pho ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que c'est une nymphe à 11,9
au masculin comme hambourg le mois et
grand-mère info adam vous servir une
information et grand mère oui admin
chéri cela veut dire quoi dame au
chapeau
ça veut dire ça chanteur belge est
d'accord les grands-mères comment
humains juin alors ça écoute je ne sais
pas je ne sais pas du tout est clair
oui quoi papa il a fait un bisou sur la
bouche à la baby sitter il a fait ça
j'aurais été sur un coup terrible à pau
grand mère oui ma soeur elle a dit
[ __ ] ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que c'est quelqu'un qui
vous prend par derrière
ça m'amuse
grand meilleur pourquoi chirac ma chérie
oui le président de la république il
paraît qu'il est convoqué chez le juge
il veut pas y aller pourquoi
et puis et puis johnny hallyday il a une
mercedes et puis toi tu n'as pas grand
mère pourquoi parce que là on a sept
français et grand mère oui papa il était
sur le lit il est monté sur le baby
sitter
et puis ça lui a fait mal elle avait mis
si tel n'était pas de crier pourquoi
elle criait grand mère parce qu'ils se
rendent pas compte qu'il est qu'il est
lourd
j'aimerais
mais oui pourquoi dieu il a il n'a pas
de femme qu'il aime pas les hommes
secret
et maintenant on reçoit maintenant
l'avocate de michel blanc sophie bottai
et le député qui l'a accompagné à bali
thierry mariani
m
bonsoir à tous les deux donc c'est un
bon soir sophie bonjour jai donc qu'ici
on connaît bien l'histoire parce que
c'est pas mal occupé du cas
michaël blanc il est donc à bali en
prison depuis 17 mois
parce qu'il s'est fait choper avec
nuages confort ne va pas vraiment la
preuve
et puis il est condamné surtout à
perpétuité donc vous êtes allé là bas
vous avec une autre avocate
quito voilà et vous donc vous êtes
député
le député rpr du vaucluse de valréas et
vous êtes partis aussi là bas parce que
vous intéresser aux cas de michaël blanc
alors vous allez rencontrer je crois que
c'est vous ce fait que rapporter les
personnalités judiciaire et politique en
indonésie pour les sensibiliser à un
petit peu au cas de michaël blanc oui
tout à fait nous avons rencontré avec
chantal quito donc à jakarta d'abord
tout ce qui compte dans la diplomatie
cette année l'ambassadeur et la consule
générale qui nous ont donné de
nombreuses preuves de leur mobilisation
à nos côtés ça a été assez formidable
notamment l'ambassadeur nous a permis
grâce à une intervention auprès du
directeur des affaires criminelles de
d'avoir accès aux scellés et de pouvoir
procéder une sorte de contre enquête et
aden passa au tribunal et à sa capitale
de ben ali
absolument nous sommes donc à les
examiner les scellés et les pièces à
conviction ou tout le moins ce qu'il en
reste car pas mal de documents ont
disparu mais certains étaient là et
c'était important parce que par exemple
nous avons constaté que le tag et qui
que je voulais voir le tag du bagage
je voulais m'assurer que le poids des
bouteilles au départ de bombay par
exemple était le même que celui là dans
les bouteilles faut le dire pour nos
amis téléspectateurs quand pas tout
suivi dans ses bouteilles de plongée
on avait mis le 8 de la chine voilà et
donc 3 kg 8 de haschich c'est tranquille
au 8
voilà donc sur le code barres du tag en
général vous avez le poids des valises
mais ce cette pièce avait étrangement
disparu et nous avons quand même
en fouillant dans les billets d'avion et
le biais de retour pu découvrir une
pièce qui à mon avis nous permet de dire
que les constatations nous avons faites
sont contraires à celles que les
policiers douaniers balinais ont réalisé
par exemple nous avons constatés et que
ces bouteilles étaient passés aux rayons
x et à bombay et à bangkok puisque
michael était une correspondance et nous
avons
vu les le petit document de sécurité de
bombay et de bangkok c'est à dire que
les douaniers n'ont rien vu dans ces
deux stops
ouais étrangement et quand on a eu la
balle du haschich dedans absolument
ouais comme ça rejoint la thèse de
michaël blanc qui pensent faire lui ses
parents d'ailleurs qui pense que tout ça
a été organisé pour faire un exemple en
les juges de la cour suprême ont
toujours pas fixé la date de l'arrêt
alors l'arrêt normalement doit être
rendu le 30 juin
il y aura deux hypothèses soit la
décision n'est pas cassée et sa
condamnation à la réclusion criminelle à
perpétuité et confirmés soit la cour de
cassation cass et alors là plusieurs
hypothèses soit le cas celle renvoi
devant un tribunal correctionnel soit
elle ceci dit elle même du dossier et
elle peut augmenter car l'avocat général
requiert à nouveau la peine de mort elle
peut confirmer perpétuité ou elle peut
diminuer plancher 20 ans donc rien n'est
réglé là pour le moment loin de là pas
du tout leur métier
ben ali vous avez rencontré les parents
de michaël blanc qui étaient là bas
comment il va lui après 17 mois de
détention dans un stress épouvantable
vous pouvez l'imaginer parce que sa vie
est un enfer encore que les conditions
de détention sont moins drastiques
qu'avant avant il était dans une énorme
cellule avec dix étaient soixante ans
passés à lui balancer la nourriture à
même le sol c'était terrifiant
aujourd'hui dans une cellule avec un
jeune autrichien il n'est pas maltraité
à l'électricité depuis un mois est bon
il le vit un peu mieux et surtout il ya
de l'espoir je crois qu'il a l'espoir de
voir que l'on s'occupe de lui de voir
qu'on a réalisé cette contre-enquête et
quand on a constaté que n discutable le
mans il avait été piégé et balancer et
que la diplomatie en coulisses est en
train de comprendre qu'il est victime
d'une injustice est en train de bouger
justement qu'on passe avoue thierry
mariani donc député du vaucluse comme je
les dis maire de valréas l'enclavé de
valréas
vous avez décidé de proposer au
parlement français un traité de
transfèrement entre la france et
l'indonésie qui permettrait donc
finalement à michaël blanc si sa passe
est de pouvoir peut-être purger sa peine
en france au moins quoi la plus
exactement j'ai demandé au ministre des
affaires étrangères justement d'entamer
les négociations pour faire ce traité de
transfèrement qu'est ce que c'est qu'un
traité de transfèrements seront traités
entre deux pays où ces deux pays
il en existe par exemple avec le maroc
avec la thaïlande avec les états unis où
ces deux pays décident une fois qu'un
condamné je peux dire connaissent à
peine de manière ferme dans le pays où
il a pris sa peine d'être ramené dans
son pays d'origine pour y purger sa
peine et surtout pour avoir cette peine
aménagée dans les conditions de ce pays
d'origine ouais en clair ça permettrait
à michaël blanc le jour où sa
condamnation est définitive
ouais d'être de revenir en france grâce
à ce traité ensuite de bénéficier des
conditions d'aménagements de peine de
révision et cetera qui existe en france
une bonne espoir pour sa auprès du
parlement français non je crois que
c'est surtout ministre des affaires
étrangères d'entamer très vite les
négociations pour ce genre de traiter il
en existe déjà plusieurs entre
différents pays y a pas d'implications
financement oui le problème thierry et
sophie c'est qu'en fait là-bas la
situation politique est très tendu en
indonésie il ya ce président aveugle à
qu'on voit à la télé ou même comme ça
qui m'a plu le pouvoir il ya là
il veut la fille du fondateur de
l'indonésie de la fille de ce qu'arnaud
qui essayent de reprendre le pouvoir
enfin c'est une observation pense que ça
pourrait être megawati sukarnoputri
prennent le pouvoir à partir du mois
d'août - et donc à ce moment là il y
aurait d'interlocuteurs et c'est qu'il
manque c'est compliqué la donne
oui bien s'il revient en france ça veut
dire qu' il pourrait être en fait
libérer que passer de 2,5 ans tu vois le
paradis faut quand même savoir que trois
kilos et demi de la chiche en france
pour quelqu'un qui n'a jamais été dans
l'année c'est entre 18 mois et deux ans
et demi de prison bien alors qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire pour mickaël parler de
lui comme vous le faites formidablement
thierry ardisson ben oui les autres et
jean-pierre montaner et les autres on a
décidé qu'on laissera pas tomber et
l'aider parce que je crois que ce qu'on
peut se dire c'est que ça pourrait
arriver à chacun de nos enfants bien sûr
et que je compte bien les soutenir ici
il ya une question de pognon aussi bon
j'aurais pas été toujours ça mais il
faut aller sur le site passe ya beaucoup
de gens qui sont branchés déjà trois ou
quatre cent mille internautes qui sont
branchés sur ce site
donc c'est vrai que les parents de
michaël blanc ne serait ce que pour vous
payer ne serait-ce que pour des payer
déplacement parce qu'elle en a donné si
ça coûte cher
donc les paroles michaël blanc besoin
d'argent tout simplement faut envoyer
200 bâle iii sans mal voilà c'est tout
parce que ça coûte cher tout ça alors on
pas rentrer dans le débat rassurez-vous
mariani mais je veux quand même dire vu
que vous êtes là je peux pas ne pas vous
le dire
vous êtes le créateur de ce qu'on
appelle l'amendement mariani pour
contrôler les rêves
oui voilà c'est mon avis et c'est le
travail classique d'un parlementaire de
terrain qui a qui a vécu ce genre de
manifestation sur le terrain qui sans
les interdire veut simplement limiter
certaines leurs effets négatifs
c'est ce que vous dites vous c'est que
quand on veut organiser c'est un autre
sujet mais c'est important parce qu'il
est là ça nous intéresse les gens qui
nous regardent à cette heure là
j'imagine c'est que quand on veut
organiser une règle il faut une
autorisation préalable c'est ce que vous
demandez on va pouvoir s'amuser faire la
fête mais on doit respecter le terrain
doit respecter les voisins on doit
simplement prendre quelques précautions
en rentrant sur ce studio j'ai vu les
pompiers et puis enfin je crois qu'on
peut pas fermer les yeux aussi sur
certaines trafic qui se font dans ses
frères bien alors vous on a parlé de
vous la semaine dernière avec christine
deviers-joncour parce que vous êtes
également l'avocate de christine deviers
joncour et on voulait on vous a fait un
triomphe roma la semaine dernière c'est
très courageux parce qu'il ya des gens
qui m'ont dit allez j'ai reçu des
e-mails me disant oui m'enfin
quant à christine deviers-joncour tu
déconnes avec elle et où tu parle pas du
fond de la sphère le fond de la faire on
le connaît il fonde la faire c'est yael
fonds connaît l'affairé elf aujourd'hui
ce qu'il faut aussi ouvrir le dossier
des frégates de taïwan comme le dossier
pas ouvert les personnes veulent ouvrir
je vais pas en parler puisque toute
façon c'est pas possible
et vous vous avez eu beaucoup de courage
vous allez déposer le dossier des
frégates sur le bureau du juge
et vous risquez vous risquez quoi c'est
serré principe ça des poursuites de la
part du parquet pour violation du secret
d'instruction
voilà mais je crois qu'on était dans une
telle impasse que je n'avais plus le
choix et un moment donné je crois qu'il
fait qu'il ment quand on fait ce métier
il faut prendre des risques foyer
jusqu'au bout sinon on ne défend pas que
voilà j'en trouve voilà donc ce que je
répète tous ces gens qui ont écrit dans
les journaux et qui m'ont envoyé des
emails c'est que le problème c'est les
frégates mais c'est pas moi qui peut
ouvrir le dossier des frégates de taïwan
puisque ça ne m'appartient pas voilà
c'est malheureusement le le le problème
clé de cette affaire parce que on l'a
juste pour avoir reçu de l'argent
donc on a juste d'un recel mais on ne la
juge pas la chance de jouer on ne joue
même pas le procès qui pourrait
expliquer pourquoi elle avait droit à
cette commande dont la légitimité de son
droit comme ça c'est le dossier des
frégates
alors je les prie je les poser sur le
bureau du
voilà c'est merci
or ben c'est maintenant bla une pièce
qui la séquence finale de cette émission
et pour arbitrer le blind test
j'accueille major philippe hugon
oui
m
non
cortina monsieur saint philibert et des
donc arbitrer le blind test qui ce soir
est un blind test spécial joujou didier
[Musique]
quant au diable si un souffle à j 1
paire d'as bien alors vous connaissez la
règle du jeu c'est pas compliqué donc ça
tourne autour des jouets des joujoux je
vous demande
l'interprète
le
chansons magnifiques chansons je joue à
la casse bravo vous êtes une bonne
avocate et en plus vous glacer bien et
d'avignon mais je les petits aucune
réponse est oui bah oui ouais pareil
faux pas manon travail pendant plus haut
continue limites
m
que se passe-t-il que se passe-t-il je
vous demanderais toi toi que se
passe-t-il on continue
oui
john baird
alors kévin alors les voitures en deux
et les poupées en d'accord at his on
n'avait pas dit ça mais on comprend pas
toujours bien nous oui c'était pas
toujours ailleurs c'est vrai on continue
l'interprète
alors maintenant il va enlever
évidemment les disques az c'était chez
europe 1 donc il connaît déjà normal et
naturel
maintenant malgré une autre version de
cette chanson
oui
m
ça c'est dur c'est christina didier
chanson numéro 5
[Musique]
mardi
m
est-ce que ça mérite un replay serge
petit replay parce que ça se joue entre
le vayer mariani un replay petit replay
[Musique]
je suis là
je sais chance en numéro 6
l'interprète cristaux
parce que génial c'est qui fait chier
pour les rêves mais il est plutôt bon de
l'intérieur bah oui 7
paris
le souffle
pas bon c'est vrai que c'est en parlant
[Applaudissements]
c'est marié tu es marié tu es marié deux
enfants sérieuse mais bon il est allé
droit y est maudit pluie dans les films
way
le souffle
c'est qu'un marianne c'est vrai c'est
vrai 2 5e balle pour toi qu'est-ce qui
s'est tenue le truc là j'ai envie de
m'inscrire jeu
voilà c'est jean marie bigard des dames
messieurs chanson numéro huit viviers
[Musique]
quand je fais un petit garçon
jean marie bigard n'était donc ça fait 3
pour les poupées et 5 pour les voitures
c'est bien je suis d'accord tu es
d'accord à bascule arbitre je suis
d'accord 3 sec 23/100 chanson numéro 9
c'est dur
même ça ça lui a
le ministre
la main
hélas
c'est celui bien plus fier
charlene a trouvé non à monsieur c'est
celui qui a fait le jerk a dit ara
morgane elle a raison puisque c'est
thierry hazard
le coin
et maintenant nous arrivons super banco
alors ils vont vous allez voir à quel
point la vie est injuste c'est à dire
que maintenant celui qui gagne l'équipe
i came et super banco a gagné le blind
test même si les dernières la première
c'est l'injustice de l'aviron but
symboliser d'une façon extraordinaire
le didier le super bowl
bon c'est bon
m
[Applaudissements]
non c'est pas facile c'est pas très sage
était vraiment pas facile bravo mr bah
oui tout est naturel en bon voilà c'est
pas une nouvelle mais donc voilà donc
c'est sylvie joly et l'équipe des
petites voitures qui emporte tout merci
à tous
c'était du monde en parle
mais pour qui je m'entends ciel
elle le disque la la la la la
et en tournée dans toute la france
pour bercy
voilà
ville avant quelqu'un tue deux vidéos
diamant 390 m
soixante mille délégués milliardaire le
mec
la boîte qui sort le
juillet lambert wilson pour les films
une pelle en service le 13 juin avec
j'ai donné françois berléand landes
jackie berroyer stéphane déracinés
et qui met en scène aussi lambert wilson
avec kristin scott thomas les 7 8 et 9
juillet pour la 14ème édition des
estivales de perpignan
morgan morgan
[Applaudissements]
en cinq ans elle à la visionne soirée
hot d'or voilà
jackson richardson
capitaine de l'équipe de base ball avec
des guides de france au tournoi de paris
jusqu'au 10 juin
à bercy
allez vivant
président de la chaîne parlementaire
ali saremi rodez presse sur france
musique ivan levaï interne la devise des
mots chez michel lafon
spitz et du groupe texas les plus grands
x voilà mixage le may arida les trois
inédits dont guide
là il un spa
c'est le single est en promo sylvie joly
c'est lui je les voir
visualisez
reid hall et donc au casino de paris
jusqu'au 16 juin et le cd look élevé ce
top 10 qu'elle ferait deux civils
c'était
l'église vous remercier m soit 10 beauté
avec un délégué
et le défilé jean-paul des thierry
mariani merci les coucher par terre du
vaucluse wallace et la sortie en vidéo
et un dvd du spectacle de franck dubosc
je vous ai pas raconté ça existe aussi
au real cette voie là c'était tout le
monde en parle
l'émission pas club les au rendez vous
samedi prochain
non
[Musique]
jamais
non
[Musique]
m
paris
il m
[Musique]
du baby boom
quand
es tu
[Musique]
m
ah ah
[Musique]
nous
non
[Musique]
no
non
[Musique]
on
m
[Musique]
non
mr
[Musique]
non
nov
m
non
[Musique]
et